[Musique]
oh
oui oui m maupassant annoncé valls et
valentin l'appareil oui la fée richter
oui je sais oui oui vous avez a signé ce
matin ont débouté d'opposition c'est
bien ça oui c'est bien non non ça donne
noro se donne trois semaines de répit à
votre adversaire tout au plus tout au
plus oui oui là la date du jugement
dernier
alors non non la date du dernier
jugement eux attend attendez attendez
attendez mettre vos passagers le dossier
sous la main 24 janvier oui 24 oui oui
oui
trois mille litres de mazout
non je ne confonds pas bien maîtres mots
passants mais non mais ce mélange n'est
jamais commenté 3000 litres de mazout
voyons accroché nom qui demande et vous
monsieur bolbec
oui c'est ici c'est la part de qui la
maison gardois et charbon robin quitté
non non non non non acquittées planant
city c'est ici mais nous alors c'est
parce que je parlais avec quelqu'un mais
ça n'était pas pour chercher ce qu'ils
aiment pas ne quittez pas me quitter pas
l'équipe ne quittez pas ne quittez pas
je ne sais pas ne quittez pas monsieur
je trouvais qu'on vous demande à
l'appareil qu'est ce qu'il ya qu'est ce
que c'est
la maison d'armes ou jay fois qu'il vous
propose du mazout ah oui je suis au
courant
richard moore oui alors dites moi vous
avez reçu ma lettre
comment mes reproches ne sont pas
fondées je commande 3000 litres de
mazout pour remplir la cuve et vous me
faites des pauses et 3 tonnes d'entrain
site que votre libraire absolument voulu
laisser dans le couloir de l'appartement
ma vie ça fait beaucoup et ça fait
désordre
qu'est-ce que vous lécher creuser une
galerie pour rentrer maintenant je vais
essayer
bon enfin trêve de plaisanterie faudra
porter oui il faut me faire l'échangé le
plus vite possible
voilà je connais en revoir monsieur le
garde corps monsieur becca vrai maître
de maison
il faut bien monsieur valentin dites-moi
est-ce que vous avez vu ma femme ce
matin vous l'avez elle va bien c'est un
mois que que vous demandez ça n'avait
pas ce que moi je n'ai pas vu depuis
hier soir au dîner
oui cette affaire douguine il absorbe
tellement c'est probable il ya soit tout
de suite après le dîner les vieux
s'enfermer dans son bureau
elle a travaillé jusqu'à 2 heures du
matin quand elle est venue se coucher je
dormais quand elle s'est levée ce matin
je dormais encore voyez vous dormez
beaucoup je dors normalement sur dix 10
heures c'est bien ce matin je pas pu la
voir non plus alors sur des clients
toute la matinée
enfin à une heure arthur est venu me
dire madame est servie son fusil enfin
je vais la voir elle va pas du tout mon
couvert et amy elle était déjà parti
depuis une demi-heure en emportant un
sandwich et va monsieur valentin j'ai
déjeuné tout seul
faux mais oui m bolbec plaque ce
matin-là faire trier l'audience était
pour 1h 13 heures malgré mais si ça
continue comme ça elle va tomber malade
qui sommes là ma femme m bolbec ces
masses et votre famille il faut le
répéter le ton malades regardez moi tous
ces dossiers ce soit une catastrophe je
sais bien que mal ramé de bien
grand bonhomme seulement des dons à quel
est ce qu'elle va rentrer je ne sais pas
je ne sais pas qui leur étaient quatre
au monde à mon avis il va pas tarder
parce qu'elle aura encore beaucoup de
travail qu'on fera dites moi monsieur
valentin est ce que vous croyez
est ce que vous croyez que vous pourrez
la voir je ne sais pas enfin je lui
demande
bon je vous remercie l'enchaînement
silencieux valente mais qu'est ce que
c'est arthur et le couturier de madame
qui on voit un couturier c'est parti le
l'othello lot où ces mots un foutu une
robe
ma femme a encore des idées de femmes
auront la bonne journée est ce que le
livre est reparti oui je suis là pour
savoir s'il n'y a rien à redire au nom
n'y a rien à reprendre un bon gars de
tout et vous lui donnez 500 enfants de
ma part j'ai gagné templiers qu'on
analyse en mamie fille je n'aurais
jamais osé espérer ça oui il faut dire
que c'est janvier qui plaidait pour lui
non mais les bêtises qui l'appuient
clients qu'est ce que c'est que ça
harting mirettes une robe contraint
d'apporter combat mais je sais ce que
s'est posée salage et servez tout à
l'air il ya deux personnes qui attendent
au salon depuis 3 ou encore écouter
bisauta seulement quand je vous avais
dit je ne voulais plus recevoir pierce à
nos jours ils ont tellement insisté le
monsieur surtout made in ils
attendraient jusqu'à demain matin à
temps parce qu'ils ne sont pas ensemble
normal alors tu vois quand ils sont
arrivés ils ne se connaissaient pas
maintenant il ya de ça trois au cours
des salons partir ça va bien vite en
vous ouimette oui vous n'avez plus votre
tête
mais si m pourquoi si c'est vous qui
m'avez préparer mon dossier templiers ce
matin louis maître vous ai oublié
quelque chose mais il note simplement la
prochaine fois faites attention ma femme
est déjà c'est sûr mener comme ça toi
mais je suis là où je suis je suis
toujours là bonjour ma chérie tu n'es
pas trop fait avant moi jamais toi otéra
la boxe a enfin ça va mieux ça va pas
plus marrant toi mon gars tu as joliment
be a dormi cette nuit j'ai dormi normal
mon goût du jour chez bbc dormi leader
des tas de machins est-ce que tu as cinq
minutes là à m'accorder
ah oui je pense bien tu as des choses et
me dit on l'a énormément bande alors je
t'écoute et à box
je ne sais plus par laquelle commencé
lorsque ray dépêche toi chérie mais je
voulais te dire il faut absolument
il faut il faut il faut absolument que
tu déjeunes commence non pas avec moi ce
serait trop beau mais ils font tous les
jours
non il faut absolument que j'essaie
marocain vient m'aider vivent bien
bon je vais essayer de monthois et 1 et
devant volant taureau c'est inouï
c'était en hausse et une robe d'avocat
évidemment on aurait dû gross et ses
ravissants axe
en haut bah non c'est pas vrai c'est
ridicule c'est pas possible non enfin
les manches sont étroites et ricky
barnes pas d'ampleur pardon volée et
c'est triste comme un voleur oui enfin
ça je peux dire
comprenez-moi bien suivez mon
raisonnement
non messieurs je ne vous crois pas mais
le grand mouvement de son interface je
ne peux pas dire cet homme est innocent
je prends le ciel à témoins et ben voilà
des noms n'ont pas c'est qu'une robe
pour lé tribunal de commerce on sait qu
une robe d'assises
on sait même pas drôle de
correctionnelle le lot n'ont jamais dû
plaider
c'est pas possible bon dieu quelle heure
est il
c'est effrayant sas est effrayant c'est
des gens à voir j'ai à travailler avec
elle vit oui j'allais le dire tu vois
donnez moi le dossier d'aubigny valentin
le dossier mobinil éventuelle adoption
ce que si j'avais encore beaucoup de
choses à dire mais je je vois que tu es
très occupée je chercherai une autre
occasion de te joindre commando mon
chéri quand tu voudras quand je voudrais
être
à l'instar de m oui mais je vous ai
demandé le dossier d'aubigny oui bien
m'être bien eh bien regardez paramount
contre marquis d'or ce nom il y en a
tant il y en a tant de mauvaises raisons
on ne discute pas parce que vous avez vu
quelques temps après le dossier loving
quand vous êtes entré chez moi sur la
recommandation du président perron joli
ça fait combien de neuf mois m c'était
le 14 mai dernier à 9h18 du matin à la
bonne heure je retrouve un peu de cette
précision d'esprit qui m'a tout de suite
frappé chez vous car les premiers temps
vous avez été secrétaire de tout premier
rang aussi si si si précis ponctuelles
méthodique n'y en a pas eu une idée
avoué adoptant aveuglément tout les
miennes enfin le rêve au métro enfin le
bas ne me remerciez pas aujourd'hui
n'est pas du tout les mêmes problèmes
mais vous avez conservé votre
personnalité ça il persiste et vous êtes
devenu distribuer vous n'êtes pas ce
qu'on vous dit ça dépend qui parle
ben oui oui nous avons écouté c'est
entendu enfin il faut aussi écouter les
clients rencontrent les clients comme
moi vous avez dix ans les pignons quant
à valentin mais qu'est ce qui ne va pas
vous jouez à la boue
non m mais le rachat gré vous vous avez
perdu un parent non mais oh non il
souffrait de l'estomac vous avez des
lévres alci ou non du tout du tout du
tout je suis un peu amoureux mais l'âme
bon eh bien il n'ya pas là de quoi
perdre la tête à vous coucher avec elle
non c'est une jeune fille elle a épousé
là je ne peux pas elle est déjà mariée
et elle aime son mari
je ne crois pas bon ben alors qu'elle
divorce je plaiderai pour elle et puis
vous les posez non écoutez votre écoute
et mettre ça vous traitez gatti ici on
parle l autre chose
moi je ne demande pas mieux parlons
d'autres chiens ne tenez ne parlera plus
qu est faite entre l une des personnes
qui sont au salon il faudrait pas les
faire attendre pour bien vous n'avez
plus besoin de moi m non non non non ça
va bien merci
asseyez vous madame oui asseyez vous et
l'apa là mais à qui ai-je l'honneur
madame je m'appelle cécile pointé
attendait cécile pointe samedi quelque
chose est-ce qu'on ne m'aurait pas écrit
à votre sujet si si m croquer zadi vous
écrira mais oui parfaitement m maître
croc est né voilà sa lettre o o excusez
moi si j'avais su je ne vous aurais pas
fait attendre si longtemps
merci madame enfin c'est fait c'est fait
oui m caucase me dire deux mots qu'il
s'agit d'un divorce
oui eh bien je suis très flatté cassure
des faux m crocker et penser à moi il
n'a pas hésité il a écouté mon histoire
et il m'a dit je regrette moins de ne
pas pouvoir plaider pour vous votre
affaire n'est pas bonne pour vous gagnez
ça il vous faut de l'astuce des qualités
extérieur de la mauvaise foi il vous
faut une femme allait trouver métro
bolbec
il m'a nommé comme ça tout de suite tout
de suite il a consulté l'année un parent
alphabétique
alors que vous êtes dans les baies bon
donc votre affaire n'est pas il paraît
eh bien nous allons tâcher de la vendre
meilleur merci madame
mais après moi m une madame et racontez
moi votre frère voilà je vais plein
divorce soit prononcé pour moi je veux
que tous les torts soit du côté de mon
mari et je veux une pension d'au moins
500 mille fois par mois mais combien
gagne t il votre mari neuf cent
cinquante mille francs
ben vous êtes exigeante ah non je ne
peux pas dire à moins de 500 mille fois
par mois bon ben si tous les torts sont
du côté de votre marque
je vais bien et tous les torts c'est
beaucoup dire mais enfin pour quelles
raisons demandé le divorce mais c'est
pas moi qu'ils demandent c'est lui oui
mais enfin pourquoi parce qu'on rentre
en voyage l'autre jour vers 5 heures de
l'après midi il m'a trouvé toute nue
où ça mais chez nous dans notre chambre
c'est pas grave
mélo mais il y avait un monsieur avec
moi à a tenu aussi aux eaux 1 mais
qu'est ce que vous voulez mon mari ne
m'avait pas prévenu qu'il rentrait il
perd escales lunéville jusqu'au
lendemain
alors c'est de sa faute et c'est tout ce
que vous avez à lui reprocher à votre
mari c'est pas tout il est chaud il a du
ventre et fume trop écouté mais je suis
extrêmement occupés par des affaires
beaucoup plus sérieuse que la alors
rouvre l'annuaire à la lettre c ces
miliciens de beaucoup de mes confrères
wundrack embarras du choix pour moi je
n'aime pas faire d'autre on va alors
basculer fait on alors mais qu'est ce
que vous a fait madame c'est plein pour
la fleur est un peu difficile mais c'est
justement pour ça que je vous ai choisis
un an ferme vous m'avez choisie parce
que monsieur prothèse à consulter
l'annuaire pas rendre à sa boutique au
début peut-être mais après pourquoi
après si vous saviez tout ce qu'on m'a
dit quand j'ai annoncé que je vous
promets pam avocat et qu'est ce qu'on
vous a été mais que j'ai été sauvé par
bleus et vous étiez la seule qui puisse
me gagner ce mois celle un hic c'est
toujours dans les affaires est plus
difficile que vous avez eu vos plus
grands succès qu'est ce qui vous a dit
ça tout le monde a et bien vous avez eu
le temps de raconter votre affaire à
tout le monde ça la rend plus en plus
difficile alors vous devez être content
un os
quand votre mari vous a surpris en
flagrant délit il était seul quand il
était avec deux messieurs abbas et
fashion week et le commissaire de police
du carré et son secrétaire
abbas est très fort il n'y avait pas
douteux sur quoi madame non après mois m
oui madame
bon rien à faire de doute sur le délit
le délit oui enfin ça flagrance enfin
qu'est ce que vous faisiez avec ce
monsieur tout nu l'amour mettrait m
via dommage que votre mari vous ai pas
eu à faire de blé plus intéressant pour
moi un abc que je sais vous que
d'efforts tant pis a tant attendu
il a du vent entre pointait il fume trop
intimité pénible contact déplaisant il
dégage certainement une odeur
insoutenable
je peux pas dire eh ben moi j'ai le
direct avec ça il est brut 1 passionnés
avides de chair fraîche
alors profitant lâchement des droits que
lui confère la loi ils se ruent sur sa
femme le cigare aux lèvres et sans cesse
il impose à ce petit corps fragile et
délicat l'écrasement lubrique de son
obésité
vous exagérez m non madame je plaide
qu'il faudrait pas dire le contraire de
ce qui est mais comment ça le contraire
on peut pas reprocher mon mari d'état ça
tire je dirais même plus il aime pas
bien ça non mais quoi ça le la il a pas
beaucoup de tempérament quoi ah mais
pardon à mes ça change tout ah bon mais
c'est extrêmement intéressant ce que lui
dit là à mes froideur indifférent mépris
des devoirs conjugaux
mais d'abord qu'est ce qu'ils allaient
faire à lunéville votre mari mais son
usine et à lunéville et fabricants de
bergamote qu'est ce que c'est que ça
allait bergamote et c'est des bombes au
lit pergamon de lunéville loupiac
pointer et compagnie vous connaissez pas
non c'est bon ça youtube aux mauvaises
je vous remercie
voilà si son usine et à lunéville
il y va souvent à toutes les semaines un
ou deux jours quelque fois plus mais
vous êtes tout le temps tout seul avi et
bah c'est bon ça c'est très bon dans le
mariage celui des deux conjoints qui
délaisse clos à tous les temps une fois
il ya eu une grève à son usine il est
resté plus d'un mois absent alors je lui
proposais darryl rejoindre il m'a dit
que c'était pas la peine
et pourquoi une greffe veillant à des
bagarres perrin que ces méchants les
ouvriers en grève et bat prétexte vous
avez cette lettre oui parce que moi mais
vous avez chez vous s'il vendait bien il
me la faut dans une heure à la nôtre a
fait de bien bonnes notre affaire alors
olivier de mon avocat ouais ouais vous
êtes très gentil et puis squatté le
déboute cet homme qui vous quel est ce
qui vous empêche de le rejoindre qui
vous interdit d'être mère vous avez des
enfants un nom n'est pas parce que je
n'étais sûr il n'en veut pas seul mais
bien légal que son pays se dépeuple
heureusement que cette bonne petite
française ne s'est pas laissé contaminer
par les idées négatives de ce sans
patrie le savez vous messieurs
pourquoi la mort dans l'âme elle a
trompé son mari pour être mère
vous vous plaît dit m oui madame je
plais pas bon parce que c'est pas du
tout pour être bien que non contraire
je fais toujours très attention et bien
il faut pas dire ça
d'ailleurs bouche non plus n'aurait pas
voulu maquiller sa bouche ah oui celle
obtenue oui en fait qu'est ce qu'il est
devenu celui là bas il s'est rhabillé
évidemment et puis et puis made in and
au ton mari le commissaire de police
bien vu trop de monde bon et puis je
n'ai jamais revu ah ben alors en ce
moment vous êtes tout seul
ah oui je cherche quelqu'un au nom après
le procès si ça ne vous fait rien
combien de temps ça dure un procès entre
bosses
si suis moi si je suis moi moi jamais à
tandis que la moi attendent quoi d un
homme je m'ennuie mois déjà elles sont
enragés
bon alors un bon conseil ne vous faites
pas passer une seconde fois parce
qu'alors votre affaire deviendrait un
plaideur je fais attention
oui enfin prenez quelqu'un qui est
intérêt à se cacher lui aussi est marion
je me mêle de ce qui ne le regarde pas
alors allé me chercher les lettres de
votre mari oui les autres si vous en
avez le me serviront au revoir madame
en fait vous dire combien je vous suis
reconnaissant oui oui ça va ça va bien
un homme marié
elle pense que ça j'aurais pu un peu
probable mais à regarder
l'amour l'amour pas la deuxième personne
qui attend
asseyez-vous toi qu'est ce que tu viens
salon j'attendais que tu fasses entraîne
comment mais oui je viens de voir
non mais alors alors c'est toi la
deuxième paire ce ânonnant la deuxième
personne est toujours au salon est un
petit monsieur chose seulement à force
il s'est endormi alors j'en ai profité
pour rappeler voyons enfin qu'est ce que
c'est que cette plaisante ça n'est pas
une plaisanterie j'ai à te parler dit
dans combien de temps encore de thua
chacun des grillons je sais pas où un
quart d'heure vingt minutes c'est
inespéré et combien ça coûte la
consultation mille francs cfa
on n'a pas du tout part du budget parler
sérieusement et comme chacune des
minutes de ta vie tu les as good as tes
clients et bien je me présente à toi
comme clients doyon et moyens monsieur
qui attend alors je prends tu en as tu
ne le perds pas attention j'ai payé un
thé non franchement ça c'est
extraordinaire je serai un étrange et
hume accorderait un quart d'heure je
suis ton mari tu ne veux pas m'écouter
vous écouterez ce soir c'est non non ce
soir fera encore du travail c'est plus
je dormirai non moi je veux mon quart
d'heure maintenant elle n'essaie pas de
le passer à m'empêcher de parler à ce
serait pas honnête ce bon bon ballon
assieds toi sur ce fauteuil c'est celui
des clients
écoute alors attends j'ai fait une
petite liste pour être sûr de ne rien
oublier alors j'ai téléphoné au mazout
on s'est arrangé un bon ben alors après
à leurs attentes après y avait un leurre
victorine didot la cuisinière m'a donné
ces huit jours que beaucoup parce
qu'elle dit qu'elle aime trop son métier
pour rester chez nous qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça moi tu dois savoir ce que
ça veut dire deux mais son métier
victorinna son amour-propre elle tient à
servir de la bonne cuisine et elle dit
que chez nous c'est impossible
pourquoi le four ne marche pas annoncer
production du four dont elle se plaint
cette nous un jour tu reçois des clients
jusqu'à une heure et demie on se met à
table à deux heures le lendemain tu
demandes le déjeuner pour 11 heures
parce que tu as rendez vous au palais à
midi alors qu'est ce que tu veux comment
veux tu que le roastbeef soit cuit à
point dans ces conditions là en fait
nous ne mangeons pas du rosbif c'est
bien victorine et de mauvaise foi tu
n'as qu'à engager notre cuisinière et
voilà que tu parles c'est facile de
trouver une bonne cuisinière surtout en
ce moment à coups de manche habitat
toute la journée comme ça bon bon alors
après après quoi verbalement là
la voiture voiture qu'est ce que c'est
que ça oui alors je suis passé au garage
on n'aura pas la voiture avant samedi
quoi annoncer c'est une catastrophe
mais pourquoi j'ai pas j'y connais rien
mais m'ont dit que telle et les bielles
du del cauca que ceux d'essence alors
après j'ai cru qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ça un geste rude
gertrude enfin j'ai compté jusque là
serait ce par quoi il donnerait j'ai
encore dix minutes 1 alors j'ai tout
gertrude j'ai mal géré toute cette
attente là où ébahi par hackett a écrit
trois fois et que tu n'as jamais répondu
et c'est possible
non c'est certain alors elle m'a écrit à
moi et va bien il toujours à bordeaux
elle est toujours à bordeaux mais elle
va mal elle dit qu'elle se sont au plus
bas et que elle va peut-être même mourir
ma pauvre tante gertrude
oui eh ben il faut que tu galles mais
enfin c'est attendre c'est pas la mienne
quoi c'est la soeur de ta mère c'est
notre temps toi c moi moi c'est toi mon
violon là il y aurait beaucoup à dire là
dessus et m'a dit tu es plus le temps
j'ai plus de sept minutes trois mois ma
liste certains serviette alors dit nous
n'avons plus que trois serviettes
qu'elle se rie est de table serviettes
de table en attaque 3 qu'est ce qu'elles
sont devenues les autres des loques
avait sa suce les serviettes les nappes
le linge les draps tous allant de temps
en temps il faut le remplacer
qu'est ce que tu attends que l'on a
acheté des orients chéri intérêts de
l'argent dans ce genre et colette
alors pourquoi me porter tout ça est
bien pour que tu sois au courant ma
chérie parce que j'ai pensé que des
serviettes qui s'usent une cuisinière
qui s'en va eh bien ça risquait de
t'intéresser peut-être en tant que
maîtresse de maison
tu ne trouves pas bien grave aujourd'hui
nous non je te dire je suis pas grave je
suis là je crois que c'est montaigne qui
dit
un jour un vieux philosophe qui en avait
assez de l'hostilité des choses de la
méchanceté des gens avaient décidé de
mettre le feu à son village
oui un jour qu'il était plus en colère
que d'habitude ben tous ces gens perdent
en abondance et ben tu vois j'ai pensé à
faire la même chose que lui sa mort je
me suis dit j'habite paris
mon geste va prendre des proportions de
catastrophe nationale
alors je crois que je vais tout
simplement te tuer a ajouté arthur ou me
tuer je sais pas enfin me livrer à un
geste sensationnel et définitif
enfin pourquoi et non pourquoi parce que
je ne te voit jamais et que j'en ai
assez écouté mon finition sept comédiens
tu arrivé ici en client tu m'as donné
vingt mille points j'ai apprécié comme
il se doit la forme humoristique de
cette petite somme enfin que tout de
même pas exagérer
nous nous rencontrons quelques fois tous
les 6 ou et tous les jours tous les
jours en cours ont une parole vague un
baiser distrait tu ne m'écoutes ni quand
je te parle mais quand je t'embrasse ya
qu à la barre que tu admets l'exorde et
la péroraison edmond soient franches
colette
depuis un an je t'ai eue à moi tout seul
trois jours de suite parce que tu étais
malade
les 14 15 et 16 décembre du banc si je
me rappelle d'état a même aux appels
j'ai dû me coucher à la suite de la
faire beau doigt mais j'avais plaidé
11h02 si tu t'étais claque
cet acompte en gt gt1 contrarié que tu
sois malade et je me disais enfin il va
mettre possible d'avoir une conversation
suivi avec elle je t'en fiches il a
fallu préserver tes cordes vocales on a
interdit de parler pendant trois ans je
ne sais vraiment vraiment ussel mari
idéal pour une femme qui varient à la
fin je serai bien et didon quoi mais
c'est vrai que je t'ai pas vue depuis
hier à dîner fo tient coi qui a recruté
va me alain aurait sinon cela fait
plaisir d'être avec toi
ah bon abbas est gentil merci
qu'est ce que tu as pu hier soir raconte
j'étais au cinéma ah bon film
merveilleux merveilleux la vie privée
des laines de sparte dit la belle hélène
ont tu ces neuf mois avant la naissance
d'hélène quand on assiste à la rencontre
entre les dai et jupiter qui s'est
déguisé en signe c'est d'une beauté ces
dunes c'est d'une exactitude en son sens
on sent vraiment que ça s'est passé
comme ça ou apprentis les matchs tu me
fais penser que j'ai un arbitrage à 6h30
bon mais quel rapport
on arbitre une histoire de films très
chers tu as dis donc toi tu n'as rien à
faire jusqu'au dîner
ben non bon alors qui va rapporter maroc
sheldon et le lot
et puis tu leur expliquera ce qui ne va
pas bien oui j'ai vu les manchots coopté
tu peux pas prendre le ciel à tébessa au
moins dix centimètres de pv j'ai vu j'ai
vu alors tu me diras fait que je ne me
mêle pas ma mission était contents ravis
c'est tout ce que j'espère être au maire
le docteur comme celle de monsieur m
bolt a qui vicient prix oui calandre à
ya longtemps qu elle est proche de celle
là haut je sais tu n'aimes pas mon
animal au nom alors et puis son mari non
plus hein
moi j'aime pas les hommes et les femmes
qui travaillent et puis les maris qui
s'amusent bonjour
les pollens vous vous avez un bon ça n'a
pas du tout docteur je vais très bien tu
es très heureux je suis très content
mais c'est loin et brandon santé tahrir
d'après tu dévoiles examine je monte
encore pas pourquoi quand j'ai le temps
justement est-ce qu'il va passer un
terreau où ça vous fait une heure nulle
part j'ai pas mal là avez-vous fait
analyser vos urines
non non non non non je pense fait
analyser mesurer et bien il faudra et si
vous m'apportez l'analyse c'est ça un
soir où on ira dîner chez vous je donne
pas un dîner savez bien vous me
l'apporter à mon cabinet puis si elle
est mauvaise et bien je me sens vrai
mais bon ce sera un charmant dit non il
a fait quelque chose dans la vessie quoi
un calcul il m'a pas boire assez
d'autres on arrive non mais regardez là
non mais regardez ce qu'elle misait on
vous avez votre analyse après demain
elle va se payer chez moi six heures
c'est justement mon jour de
consultations et bien non madame je ne
serai pas chez vous à 6 heures pourquoi
parce que si j'ai un calcul dans mon
rein j'ai encore être sondée par un
vieux monsieur chaud décorer avec des
lunettes que j'appelle moi un docteur
quant à vous ma chère amie ou benzema le
sondé
ils n'aiment pas les femmes qui
travaillent ils voudraient qu'on
accompagne au cinéma et aux expositions
présentent ils n'ont rien à faire dans
la vie ton edmond haut à conseil
d'administration dont on va bien aussi
mais enfin en plus il assombrit gc
maîtresse comment ses maîtresses mon
mari tout bon heureusement pour lui le
pauvre garçon je m'occupais du matin au
soir
alors la nuit dame je suis pas très
brillante j'ai besoin qu'on me relais un
peu ya quelque chose que je demande à
mon mari c'est de ne pas lire son vrai
nom okwara cause de ma clientèle dû
comprendre alors chaque fois qu'il me
trompe il se fait appeler le compte de
pougy sais je ne vous suis pas jaloux
c'est vrai qu'il ait trouvé ce nom là
pour faire ce que tu penses à ton mari
de prendre une maîtresse ou deux
médecins j'avoue que c'est une idée qui
mettait pas encore venu palais pourtant
logique oui mais enfin ça dépend du mari
pour moi je suis persuadé qu'ils n'ont
absolument incapable de me trompe c'est
être à lui font si mal que ça
nous agite ses grains et de son coeur
mon mari m'aide bel bien aussi même j'en
suis sûr savoyen d'une femme qu'il ait
jamais à lui alors il la remplace de
temps en temps c'est bien naturel
nouba moi je trouve ça tellement naturel
pathé guèye c'est pour me faire ce petit
cours de philosophie conjugale que tu es
venu non c'est pourtant mené ferrat tour
j'avais une grande consultation à 6
heures mais mon client est mort ce matin
est une vaine
oui bah malheureusement j'ai un
arbitrage à 6h30 il doit rencontrer cinq
personnes est impossible qu'elles soient
toutes mort ce matin à 6h10 et banjo par
joe west aux arbitrages avenue achever
de dépenser avec plaisir
j'ai pas de voiture valentin mais
valentin bonjour docteur je sors mon
point très bas rapporté des lettres
enfin vous lui direz de m'attendre je
serai de retour dans une
mais même s'il ya encore un monsieur qui
est au sol oui je sais ça n'a pas
d'importance paraît qu'ils donnent non
mais tu gagnes se réveiller il m'a fait
demander par arthur s'il avait une
chance d'être reçus aujourd'hui et vous
savez il ya eu d'avion à ma cape may cap
au jour dans les nuages
1 figure toi qu'il est amoureux on doit
travailler ou s'y réfère à ses marques
o'hara qui commence à croire que tu as
raison les deux choses sont
incompatibles
n'est ce pas valentin
on va en plus de l'entrée vous attendez
encore comment ce que j'attends
dommage que ses pensées mon voisin vous
me demandez ce que j'attends mais qu'on
me reçoivent monsieur je vous reçois
même jour soit essayez vous de votre
question je prends être maître baalbeck
était une fin et on vous a pas trompés
monsieur et quelle femme
et bien c'est elle que je pars ne parle
pas comme ça m baalbeck jour soit moi
c'est énorme et qui êtes vous monsieur
son mari le plaisanterie est amer
monsieur je suis le secrétaire on est
trop belle bête essayez vous je vous
écoute je lui dirai tellement
confidentielles ou non ce que vous lui
diriez aujourd'hui je le soir elle
maintient en admettant que votre visite
sont là sans importance pour adouber par
niasse une perte de temps je suis là
pour ça enfin j'avais prévu cet accueil
aussi je me suis muni d'une petite
lettre de recommandation pour mettre bol
d'un bon abandonné 2 qui de muscu et
bibi la tignasse ce jeune voyou qui a
tué une vieille femme de 93 ans à coups
de marteau et que m bolbec a fait a
quitté il ya deux ans à winfakt de 93
ans je me souviens parfaitement maîtres
bolbec avaient plaidé le crime
passionnel
oui très bonnes recommandations très
bonne bon et vous monsieur vous alors
qu'ils avaient vu tomber quand comment
pourquoi monsieur moi je ne suis pas
monsieur j'ai fait mes études à
stanislas je suis officier d'académie je
n'ai pas le plus petit écart de conduite
à me reprocher je suis un honnête homme
dans toute l'acceptation du terme accès
et mon nom et joseph avis cool
mes relations avec monsieur vie la
tignasse sont purement récente est
accidentelle oui hier soir en rentrant
chez moi je les trouvais qu'ils
cambriolaient alors nous avons engagé la
conversation me raconter sa vie ses
crimes il a gardé de mettre bolbec un
souvenir éblouissant et comme
précisément je cherchais un avocat je
vais demander une petite lettre
d'introduction de parfaite vous écoute
bon et bien bossé dessus
j'aime donc vous aime pas prêt ainsi
monsieur si on a on vous est membre
comment à moi me sens bien dans mon
histoire sera brève c'est une jeune
fille que j'aime j'ai demandé sa main on
me l'a accordé à la condition que
j'apporte 250 enfants dans les affaires
du père sur le buzz je veux voir vous
déposer une plainte contre le père mais
non monsieur il m'importe peu de perdre
ses deux cent cinquante mille francs
d'abord parce que je les ai pas et puis
deuxièmement c'est que ma fiancée mérite
sans fin que j'ai lu ça que je vois je
vois vous avez violé la jeune fille les
parents vous attaque parce qu'elle est
mineure après non monsieur je ne viole
pas laissez moi parler c'est à moi de
parler
ouais c'est depuis 15 ans je suis le
fondé de pouvoir le bras droit le
caissier principal de monsieur
bouillotte marchande g 17 faubourg sa de
monsieur bouillotte a de l'affection
pour moi et il m'a promis qu'à sa mort
il me laisserais précisément la somme de
500 mille louise et compris vous avez
perdu patience et vous avez plus
bouillante affaire banon mais non
monsieur je vous ai déjà dit que je ne
devais pas monsieur bouillotte est mort
hier matin et sans que j'intervienne je
vous assure
alors ben alors j'avais toujours les
clés je me précipite au testament qu'est
ce que j'y lis monsieur qu'est ce que
j'y lis gély qu'il laisse à son vieil
ami robin foule
le compagnon de ces dernières années un
secours de 50000 fouara alors je ne
parle pas de ce mot de secours qui est
très désobligeant et concevez ma ferme
mon indignation mon désespoir 50 mille
francs
isabelle est perdu pour moi me la donnes
que si j'attends que 250 mille francs
est en effet en effet alors et alors
mais alors qu'est ce que les causes y
fassions vous aviez pour les juges comme
faciles à retenir ce qui met du je veux
mes cinq cent mille faux puisque je vous
dis que on me les a premier devant trois
témoins la cuisinière eulalie qui est
sourde
monsieur bus un de ses amis qui est mort
depuis et le jeune qui a un fils
penchard qui fait les courses à
bicyclette et qui se rappelle très bien
la promesse de monsieur vous voulez
attaquer un testament en bonne et due
forme en poupe à sa victoire sur le
témoignage d'une cuisinière sur des
lentilles cycliste dernière doit pas une
ligne de briquettes par lemoine ticket
papier il n'y a rien c'est le désert
c'est bien fait épargner votre visite à
m emballe pas qu'elle n'aime pas qu'on
se moque bonne mais j'aimerais manque de
personnes
je croyais bonne foi que j'avais droite
jean dutourd le sur you du tout rien là
c'est épouvantable
vous aimez vous aussi bien comprendre
par r j'avais les pères du convoi avait
cinquante neuf autres je ne me marierai
pas on ne ferait pas long à lons à
l'employé que je te battre ici je
compatis alors alors allons voyons si
j'espère qu'il n'y a pas d'erreur voyons
l'écriture du testament est bien clair
c'est bien c'est bien cinquante mille
francs en toutes lettres
quatre petits zéro forfait je vais bien
qu'on sait pas devait ne s'est pas
devenir eu 5 050 500 mille francs
alors je jetais 250000 fonds à la tête
de monsieur mon beau-père et puis il me
restait encore 250 mille francs pour
faire la fête
ma fiancée deux existences brisées dans
un petit centre a déjà oublié peut-être
seulement la bouillotte 82 en gros vous
l'oubliez homme est il bien sûr les
derniers temps de sa vie ils ne
finissaient pas ses mots oubliés lettres
2 alors moi pour ne pas lui montrer à
quelques mois ses facultés message
j'ajoutais la lettre qui manquait
j'ajoutais le petit 0
quel petit 0 qu'il a oublié à un esprit
oui ah oui là là je vois perdra pas ses
intérêts sans procès ah oui j'ai ce
qu'ont bien en dessous du lot 900 milles
il avait défrayé direct oui babylon 9 e
2 e nièce un pouce à une très
intéressante est ce intéressant neuf
cent mille francs ça va leur paraître
une somme énorme les attaquons le
testament
oui je les attends disent ils plaideront
là c'est d'éviter du testateur a que six
héritiers directs ne peuvent à ce point
être frustré par un étranger vous êtes
année on sent vraiment que vous êtes
étranger à la famille
oui monsieur n'existe pas car nous leur
répondrons nous leur répondrons à ces
parents stupide que bouillotte savez
votre amour pour isabelle et que pour
s'être fait pardonner d'être mort si
tard il avait décuplé la somme qu'il
voulait c'est et geoffrey temps je
prétendre interrompez passage ici était
mort un an plus tard il faisait de vous
son légataire universel d'une folie
cosob a gagné ça comme ça au plus tard à
la sortie je comprends qu'il n'y a pas
hésité on use je ne fais rien alors la
cause n'est pas des fourneaux monsieur
bush ajoute le petit 0 et j'ai toute la
justice avec yahoo et voulait plus le
secrétaire de m et entre nous présente
renie rien à côté d'eux en jamais je ne
rends bien cirées assez monsieur baby la
tignasse de m'avoir envoyé ici j'avais
de ce champ réparer l'omission de
monsieur bouillotte et ajouter le petit
0 je suis timide rsa plume qu'il
convient vous doit être reprise par
l'opa de ça ça n'a pas d'importance
merci monsieur je vous remercie de cette
prodigieuse consultation et je vous
savez tous que vous en tirez qu'est ce
que c'est à dire était en fait entrer
pour mademoiselle ev3 paul bècle a dû
s'absenter pour un moment mais elle n'a
pu recommander de vous
et de la torre si vous voulez prendre la
peine de vous asseoir je suis son
secrétaire
bon je vais vous donner des revues pour
que vous ne soyez pas trop seul parce
que je suis dans quelques instants
vous êtes mariés ou non
oui ce quartier arabe ciel bonjour
madame je m'appelle m vous étiez dans le
salon tout à l'heure vous attendiez m
bolbec
oui mais attendez toujours je l'attends
depuis sept ans madame groupe rossel
mais ça on n'en voit pas la fin vous en
faites pas avec métro bolbec vous
gagnerez je n'en suis pas si sûr oui
vous pouvez pas content bel bat pas très
non vous m'étonnez ouais elle a fait une
excellente impression mais c'est une
femme très intelligente est jolie avec
ça non mais je suis très très joli
comment ça se fait qu'il soit avocat
moi je comprendrai sein d'une famille
qui pourrait pas trouver d'hommes mais
une femme comme celle là et cet épisode
commence que je me dise elle a peut-être
eu des malheurs il ya des femmes qui
sont obligées de travailler ou alors
elles et avec un fainéant un sale qui
qu'il oblige à travailler qui me bouffe
son argent moi je m'explique c'est comme
ça c'est agréable
vous vous trompez madame son mari n'est
pas du tout à un sale type
annan au camp nou contre est un garçon
très gentil vous le connaissez pas vous
de très bien oui
cet accompagnement mais parce que moi je
suis pour que les femmes qui soient des
femmes
ah ah ah ah ah ben moi aussi d'ailleurs
au début ça ne me disait rien du tout de
prendre m bolbec non non non parce qu'un
avocat pour moi c'est un homme mais
brouillon et puis elle a tellement bien
qu'elle fût mon affaire qui n'est pas
facile vous savez nord il s'agit d'un
divorce
mon mari m'a pincé dans son lit avec
push et ping m bolbec navire commandé
comme ça ne pas raconter mon affaire à
tout le monde
voici menée pour un divorce
non moi je viens pour une voiture qu'on
répare une cuisinière qui s'en va et une
tante qui va mourir à beaucoup de choses
oui oui du moment que ça dure depuis
sept ans
pourquoi ce que pourquoi est-ce que vous
avez trompé votre mari j'ai d'abord cru
que c'était parce que mon amant me
plaisait plus que lui oui et puis alors
maître bolbec m'a expliqué la présence à
huy alors j'ai trompé mon mari parce
qu'il est trop occupé parce que nous
n'étions pas assez ensemble et puis
alors surtout parce qu'il refuse de
donner des enfants la france lit dans le
mariage celui des deux conjoints qui
délaisse l'autre atout l'état s'efforce
maîtres bolbec qui vous à 10 ans j'ai
réfléchi depuis mais c'est pas juste
c'est vraiment pas mon mari était trop
occupé on n'était jamais ensemble
alors au lieu au cinéma au théâtre
expositions tout seul c'est pas rigolo
mais non ah mais non mais non c'est pas
rigolo
enfin vous heureusement maintenant vous
avez votre amant ab non monsieur il m'a
quitté
c'est paris un boulanger pas de même ce
jugement donne plus je suis seul alors
je m'ennuie mais je m'ennuie parce que
moi j'ai besoin de quelqu'un à côté de
moi pour qu'on se dise des choses pour
qu'on échange des idées pourquoi
s'embrassent tenait hier soir j'ai été
au cinéma
j'ai dû voir un très bon film est pas ça
m'aurait fait plaisir d'en parler avec
quelqu'un que j'aime qu'est-ce que
c'était comme fait d'os x fils de zorro
on n'était pas au même
est ce que vous étiez aussi vais moi
aussi j'étais au cinéma et moi aussi
j'étais tout seul on pas dit si on avait
su oui qu'est ce que vous avez fait
appel au cinéma je suis allé prendre une
glace aux napolitains
moi je suis rentré tout de suite et je
me suis fait des beignets aux pommes
je pense à minuit oui mais moi j'adore
faire la cuisine à l'importer leur jeu
fait dire que je la fais très bien où en
gt les femmes d'intérieur
j'aurais eu un homme qui sera un peu à
moi qui est un peu chez lui
j'aurais pas été chercher ailleurs et
quoi vous savez tenir une maison proche
vous n'y a jamais personne
on finit par chercher quick mais
évidemment et je suis sûr que lorsqu il
ne vous reste plus que trois serviettes
de table vous allez vous même en acheter
d'autres
je n'attends pas su tenir la barre que
toi je vais dans une maison gros c'est
beaucoup moins cher
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui vous prend je vous aime ça
là je vous aime comment vous
appelez-vous se situe à theix et c'est
exquis spe s'ils cessent ils pointaient
au c'est simple c'est bourgeois c'est
bel et bien cette semaine et bien c'est
bien un monde intérieur ça c'est alors
oui mais oui mais il fallait il fallait
que vous vous appeliez cécile pointait
on met pas du tout au contraire je vous
écoute je vous savoure je vous dois ça
fait sept ans que je n'ai pas entendu
des mots pareils enfin enfin une femme
qui est une vraie femme une campagne
discrète inintelligente et soumis à ces
dernières ne vous fâchez pas je vous
explique pourquoi je vous aime c'est
parce que vous n'êtes pas un être
supérieur
c'est une femme comme vous qu'il me faut
parce que moi aussi je vais aux
expositions tout seul pour eux mais moi
aussi je suis donné c'est toi aussi je
m'ennuie alors savourons les ensembles
vos beignets aux pommes
d'abord parce que je les adore depuis
vous aussi je vous adore écoutez
monsieur je me dépense pas drôle mais je
peux pas me lancer comme ça dans une
nouvelle aventure sans savoir à qui
ai-je l'honneur de parler d'abord je
m'appelle
[Musique]
et oui et oui à qui avez-vous l'honneur
de parler et oui là je peux pas vous
dire mon nom comme ça ne pas vous dire
mon nom comme ça tout de suite non il
faut qu' il faut que je vois il faut
qu'ils pensent pas cela
ça me déplaît pas attention ces faits
par sa non parce que vous prenez des
précautions méfier est ce que vous
seriez marié par hasard wima cécile je
suis mariée ça va très bien a bon bah
oui parce que m bolbec manière commenté
si je prenais un nouvel amant que ce
soit un homme marié ses maîtres bolbec
qui vous a recommandé ce à eybens et ben
vous savez qu'il faut écouter m bolbec
remise à huy a révélé
où on va je n'en sais strictement rien
voiliers mais on y va keller était le 7
heures je vous invite à dîner
oui mais moi j'attends de m bolbec mais
pourquoi ce que j'ai des lettres asie
donné et c'est tout vous tenez je vais
vous donner une grande enveloppe vous
allez mettre tout ce beau petit dans la
demande venait voilà une plume
alors vous écrivez sur la grande
enveloppe à la mona m vollebekk m bolbec
urgent urgent g&g ent algérien ge ngl
fait des fautes d'orthographe c'est
inespéré
allez maintenant vous partez vous partez
avant moi pourquoi ne nous vois pas
sortir ensemble vous frotter un taxi et
puis vous m'attendais au coin de la rue
de bellechasse et de la route barrée
parce que vous êtes fruits dans cette
l'homme qu'il me faut au monde une femme
qui va tenir ça va être pas avec puis
moment à les maintenir en vol et fils
est allé chez vous elle je vous aime je
vous aime bien merdé
[Musique]
une femme vs haut merci enfin une femme
beth arthur et vous allez remporter ce
carton chez monsieur lolo et lolotte et
quand madame reviendra vous le dirai que
monsieur ne dîne pas ce soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
maintenant c'est impossible mais non si
je ne dis pas qu'il était l'amant de sa
soeur comment voulez vous que je
justifie les revendications de ma
cliente
non n'insistez pas au revoir leur job
c'est possible qu'est ce que tu
fabriques
aimant alors ça
le maçonné la pendule va bien et bien
voir le jour mais pardon pardon l'union
encore mise à l'heure ce matin monsieur
n'est toujours pas rentré non madame
qu'est ce que je voulais dire je ne sais
pas
enfin vous êtes sûr qu'il n'y a personne
au salon non madame
bon on ment pas c'est bien tu inverses
copie du jugement ne laisseras tu pas
tes regards jusqu'à terre mais c'est
harry est ce que c'est que ça dure de
valence 6 mai à laisser traîner des
verts dans mes dossiers alors qu'est ce
que c'est que ça ce sont des faits
remettre des vergallo ouimette oui on
envie de vous devenu impossible
on va vous êtes amoureux nous fait des
verts ça vous regarde par exemple ce qui
est excessif
c'est de laisser traîner dans mes
dossiers ont fait une bonne fois pour
toutes que vous l'aimez à cette femme et
reprenez la direction de vos idées oui
mais oui mais si elle se fâche c'est un
chameau - qui sera quoi vous inquiète
alors il vous plaisent pas quoi faire je
pollue la dce patienter ça n'aurait pas
été de la discrétion
c'est moi j'écris sous sa dictée et je
vis dont on ouvre aux violentes mais
voilà c'est pas possible c'est possible
m mais c'est moi que vous aimez oui oui
vous savez le doublé mais c'est vous m
venez de me conseiller de lui dire une
bonne fois cette femme que je l'aimais
non non non écouter valablement
grandement l'otage avec un ingénieux de
glisser mes verres entre vos dossiers je
pensais que vous devinez argué que au
regard des retraites mais mon pauvre
petit mais je ne suis pas une femme moi
aussi mais comment cela vous est-il
arrivé
on veut regardant on vous écoute ans il
y a longtemps que vous êtes amoureux
nous depuis plus de 9 mois oui 9 gens
c'est le nombre na na nana na na tout de
suite en arrivant ici c'est cette
adresse
mais non mais non c'est tout naturel
vous ne vous rendez pas comme vous vous
êtes un grand avocat mais vous êtes tout
de même délicieuse à des femmes comme
vous on n'ose pas dire qu'on les aime
mais on les aime tout de même j'aurais
voulu passer ma vie avoue adorer en
silence sans que vous sachiez puis
j'avais tellement envie de lui dire
alors alors mes vers vos dossiers vous
conseille les les circonstances le lui
demande pardon
abbas est gay on voit la pensée de vous
mettre à la porte
valente au maire madame ça va devenir
impossible pour vous comme pour moi à
chaque fois qu'on me passera un paquet
je remarque que votre main pour pu vous
me regarderai tu ça s'aggrave
non non à chaque fois vous me direz
qu'on me demande au téléphone d'une
passionnée en ses valeurs ce qui vous
est arrivé là croyez-moi valente a il
faut nous c'est pas bon mais je
m'occuperai bon je trouverai une autre
située sur tes maîtres barbara m'a dit
chercher un secrétaire il a 72 ans c'est
un avocat tour pour autant mettre de me
chasser panneaux m'éloigner pas de doute
on ouvrait c'est cet amour que je vous
ai si maladroitement après plus jamais
je vous jure il ne vous apporte une rare
vous ne vous douterez même pas qu'il
existe peu à peu il se transformera en
rendez vous ment en zèle en ponctualité
je rédigerai les assignations avec
ferveur
ce jeu dépouillé votre courrier avec
ivresse et c'est avec passion que je
ferais tout vos courses
l'audition c'est que cette frénésie
serve à quelque chose
ou tout au moins à quatre caches j'avoue
dans huit jours pour vous trouver une
maîtresse
m vous n'y pensez pas très bien
croyez moi les meilleurs dérivatif et
puisque vous avez envie de faire des
courses eh bien allez dire tout de suite
au greffe du tribunal de commerce avec
passion oui bah ça si vous vous ai
rapporté moi la grosse du jugement
letournel l epa depuis la grosse vous
rapporte la grosse bête mais peu importe
la grosse la psdc rassurer bis coletto
chalon sur alys robi qu'est ce que c'est
oui c'est le monsieur que j'ai reçues il
ya quinze jours
vous savez je vous ai raconté sa visite
j'ai résumé son affaire dans la petite
note que voici
vous savez les maîtres vous savez le
petit 0,1
oui je me rappelle les héritiers attaque
c'est pour ça qu'ils ont gain dont vous
n'avez pas d'autres courses à me faire
peur
il est dans le grès ferme à 6h10 les
5-10 fenech le temps 5h10
5h10 m bon ben laden c'est bien aller
valentin j'aime être au revoir mais au
revoir
vous vous aussi arthur vous avez 5h10
oui voilà moi aussi ces grappes qui
disent exactement la même
ça prouve que ça doit être la bonne
dietmar tu as keller monsieur est il
sorti ce matin vers 11 heures madame
avec monsieur cram scène qui est venu le
chercher chez g scène et pourquoi
monsieur g scène
je ne sais pas d'où ils sortent ensemble
à présent je crois madame d'afrique un
jour ça fait la troisième fois que
monsieur g scène vient chercher monsieur
sont peut-être bien faire on ressent oui
bon bah c'est bon arthur fait entrer
mesures vis de la disco oui c'est moi
passé maître van laack elle même oui
messieurs
ah ben je préfère vous voir vous que
votre secrétaire je suis très au courant
de votre affaire aux nantis physicien
testament de monsieur bouillotte de la
jeune fille que vous aimez de la part de
bibi la tignasse en page et la une après
détaillé alors naturellement les
héritiers attaque le testament mais non
madame c'est devenu beaucoup plus grave
il parie que l'un des héritiers de
monsieur bouillotte une lettre datée du
matin de sa mort et qui contient cette
phrase quand harvey school je lui laisse
la somme de 50 mille francs
clap à l'orge a conclu que le dernier
petit 0 mais était imputable et on a
déposé contre moi et me plaît tant faux
et usage de faux
trois jeunes pensent comme moi non or
les procès en fou mais expert en
écriture les discussions interminables
sur un jambages un plat à délier ce que
ça va être ennuyeux ah bah c'est pas
malin ce que vous avez fait la
suppression rencontre mais votre
secrétariat lui tenez vous a pas écoutés
il fait des verts il est dans les nuages
il n'est jamais à ce qu'on lui dit
keller avez-vous 5h25 mais qu'est-ce qui
fabriquait ce pari vous permettez je
l'offre
j'ai plaidé une affaire de faux oui un
grattage de chèques
ça a duré trois jours en montagne est
condamné au maximum vol
allô allô le docteur prom scène pour
mettre bolbec
ah c'est toi magda oui c'est moi je te
dérange non pourrais tu pourrais tu
faire un saut à la maison entre deux
clients mais c'est pas loin non non mais
non c'est pour moi mais je ne devais pas
bien non mais pas bien du tout - je ne
sais pas tout tourne oui
invaincu gentillet a tout de suite merci
état comme ça j'ai peut-être savoir
quelque chose
j'arrive à un mauvais moment pourquoi
vous êtes malades n'ont pas toutes au
non non non j'ai dit cinq de mes amis
parce que j'avais envie de la voir
non non la vérité c'est que je suis
extrêmement préoccupé
ah ouais je veux qu'on soit oui mon
affaire est très préoccupant faut quand
même rien exagérer c'est en ce moment le
salon de l'auto il aime beaucoup ça et
puis ce sera peut-être attardés qui dans
mon mari tu n'habites y vit ici que les
avocats racontent leurs petites
histoires à leur façon les clients que
leur prix vous avez raison monsieur vous
avez raison alors qu'est ce que nous
allons faire
je vous le demande eh bien naturellement
je dire que le petit zemmour et de la
malveillante
oui seulement si nous avons tous les
experts contre nous qu'est-ce que vous
voulez que je plaide à moi vous demande
de benoît hamon c'est moi qui vous le
demande ne donne ses combats et là je
plaiderai le crime passionnel
évidemment je dirais que vous avez fait
ça pour avoir votre visage
oui oui oui oui seulement on me répondra
que c'est 250 mille francs dont vous
aviez besoin et pas 500 me et par
conséquent vous êtes un vulgaire escroc
mais je vous demande pardon de l'homme
je suis un honnête homme dans toute
l'acceptation d'une telle option est
celle de jean paul ii sera bien
difficile de soutenir face à ça ça si
vous aviez forcer le coffre fort et que
vous ayez pris deux cent cinquante mille
francs mais les mets juste juste les 250
mille francs exigés par le père que
voulait lui ai jeté à la tête
vous vous soyez présenté devant votre
fiancée pauvre nu tout nu alors tout nu
c'est une image mari oui oui alors ça ça
c'était un crime passionne large avait
quelque chose à dire en face était
défendable
jeanjean levé l'acquittement elisa vient
pas pisa ben sûrement il n'y a pas d'âge
pour faire ça et quoi ça et bien une
partie de la fortune de monsieur
beaulieu et tendons de la défense vous
avez entendu une voix et une hanche
crois pas minty je n'ai pas besoin de
forcer le coffre-fort que vous me le
suggérer non j le chiffre est la clé
j'étais son bras droit sont fondés de
pouvoir
et puis j'ai été regardée ya les scellés
mais une petite banque de papier entre
deux cachets rouge salle empêche pas du
tout d'ouvrir
alors je peux très bien prendre deux
cent cinquante mille francs rien que 250
ont pensé je suis un honnête homme dans
toute l'acceptation du texte accepté
jeudi et une petite heure alors je jette
250 mille francs au beau-père était je
me présente tout nu devant ma fiancée
comme vous le désirez avril à la chose
me paraît faisable mais ça nous
débarrasse pas de cette histoire de faux
et usage de faux qui semblait temps vous
ennuyer tout à l'heure et quel faux le
faut et louis le boul
ah mais attendez attendez oui j'attends
mais mais la plainte pour faux va tomber
dalmat bon madame un geste détruit l'eau
un geste de tueur
du moment que vous avez volé 250
millions vous n'aviez pas besoin
d'ajouter je disais oh ma part je dirais
donc que le chiffre de 500 milles
jusqu'au dernier zéro point man
bouillotte évident oui oui oui mais
quand aux 250 mille francs
ah mais non non je ne plaiderai pas le
crime passionnel
non non non non non non ça je plaiderait
non coupable vous ne les avez pas trop
juger pas à nous du moment que vous
héritez de 500 mille francs
vous n'avez pas besoin de voler 250 et
voilà la plainte pour vol qui tombe
d'elle-même elle aussi mais ça c'est une
affaire splendide
oui ça sera un très gros succès pour moi
s'il pense que ces gens là ils tombent
sur cinq serait bien c'est évident mais
est ce que vous ne pensez pas que cette
histoire de fou et de vol 20 jeté un
certain discrédit sur mon honorabilité
jusqu'à présent sans tâche puisque vous
serez quitter oui mais on va voyons
monsieur amiard m'acquitter c'est plus
qu'un honnête avoue craquer en fait les
petites montées
c'est une sanction c'est une
consécration de la netteté
vous êtes encore plus fort que votre
secrétaire combien footways au procès
intéressé n'a vu que sa part d'obtenir
en un monsieur sans aller au revoir
monsieur ou madame aura madame madame je
ne connais pas votre procès mais vous
êtes tombé dans une bien bonne maison on
vous donne de bien bons conseils
tu m'inquiètes ils t'ont coup de
téléphone j'ai lâché ma consultation
j'ai sauté dans ma prime aux bas tu es
gentil non non ça va beaucoup mieux 20
les gants je t'ai appelé je ne sais pas
ce que j'avais tourné maudit travail
trop tu vas finir par me faire de
l'année me cérébral ou le poulet pas
mauvais comme en dehors du combat bien
mais pas longtemps il faut dormir tu vas
voir ta langue ou en vilaine
bon eh ben je vais faire une ordonnance
que je ne sois pas venu pour rien tu
supportes l'eau minérale
oh oui bon évidemment prendre un grand
virage à tous les matins avec 15 gouttes
d'acide phosphorique et puis la foule de
fortifiants matin midi et soir
on arrive à bien on use très bien
toujours il faut faire quelquefois du
bien de ton mari pourquoi bien tout ça
mais parce qu'ils sont devenus intime
depuis quelques temps que tu ne savais
pas si si mais je ne savais pas que tu
le savais je suis très heureux je suis
très contente qu'ils sortent ensemble
alors est mon cas mis au courant de
l'existence
c'est moi qui l'ait mes conseillers en
fait tu ne te souviens pas notre
conversation ses joues tu m'as dit
qu'ils prennent des maîtresses il tous
les cinq mois qui les bat avez
parfaitement raison maintenant chez
tranquille a dit long pendant ce temps
dans combien de jours des ampoules
dizaine de jours très bas ça me fait
plaisir de savoir que tu as enfin
trouver la paix dans tomber nage ou est
ce que ton mari tu as raconté ce qui
leur est arrivé hier et ben non je n'ai
pas envie fuir mais la caisse qu'il
aurait tenté hier soir oui aux rats
morts
mon mari a lancé une bouteille de
champagne à la tête de l'américain qui
regardait sa maîtresse alors ils sont
pris au collet ton mari a voulu les
séparer sa pépé après une crise de nerfs
ap c'est mon mari alors
dagard scandale de glace casser la
police et puis on l'a conduit tout le
monde au poste
qu'est ce qui t'a raconté ça à mon mari
à deux heures du matin un peu éméché
avec une grande balance sur la joue
mais je vais me du collodion didou oui
c'est très ennuyeux pour nous ça
commissariat il a fallu qu'ils donnent
leur nom mais t'inquiète pas on a arrêté
puis relâché le compte de bougies et le
baron de mérode
c'est toi qui viens trouvé ce nom là ah
non non non non non non ça c'est lui
parlant de méroé non mais cette fois mon
métro quand même des pépés casse des
glaçons ramon pas qu'est ce que j'ai
fait ou les phares ne venons pas je te
pardonne pas comment tu m'inquiètes tu
me fais larcher ma consultation tu
fasses elle qui est au courant et tout
ça pour ce soit vrai quitte après un non
alors ça ce sont des trucs d'avocats
sont pas les procédures
mais qu'est ce que tu veux depuis quinze
jours iront à des heures impossibles
alors alors j'avais besoin de savoir
enfin tulle m dos ton mari je ne sais je
dois pas être ridicule se passera pas
comme ça
tiens qu'est ce que tu vas faire ça
devant j'ai tu vas prendre un amant aux
jetons prix de mode moi un homme en moi
m bolbec courant les garçonnière tu vois
ça maintenant je ne bois pas justement
c'est bien pourquoi je te conseille
l'indifférence oui eh ben il n'y a pas
que l'adultère pour punir l'adultère ya
la loi et ça c'est mon élément
1 je vais demander le divorce et je
plaiderai ma cause ouais mais tu vois
pas comment ça va se passer
ouais ça je commence par lui prendre la
moitié de tout ce qu'il a vu que nous
nous sommes mariés sous le régime de la
communauté et que quand il m'a épousée
j'avais pas si c'est bien ce qu'il a
fait là du tout que c'est bien toi je
parle de ce qu'il va faire jouer votre
mariage vous l'écoutez la moitié qui lui
reste il ne regardera pas lourd c'est
moi qui te le qu'est ce que tu vas les
verts 10e de la fortune belmont sur
place et à l'étranger on n'a jamais
déclaré un sou alors je le dis
avec toutes les précisions spectacle et
je lui fais coller la banlieue double
droit les intérêts de retard et un
rappel dont - val familiaux tiens tiens
tiens le voilà le voilà sans le sou sur
la paille à la rue est terrible non je
défends c'est la loi pour moi et tout ça
pour deux glaces cassé une bouteille de
champagne et une fille décidément nous
n'arriverons jamais à nous comprendre
je le crois en dieu magda sans rancune
et mes amitiés compte de pougy au revoir
they had rabat lapointe a fait demander
si on est un peu le recevoir avec
plaisir une affaire de divorce
je vais faire la main elle est au salon
je la reçois tout de suite dont je m'en
vais oui mais pas fâché non en propre
tiens je ne fais pas fuit tout et
conseils
ce soir je prendrai une ampoule à la
bonne heure c'est raisonnable en concert
madame pointe et je suis ravi pour voir
comment allaient très bien merci bonjour
m ah c'est bien le gars me oh comme
c'est gentil ya du nouveau
je vous écoute on arrive à me reprendre
c'est pas possible habib il est à
nouveau amoureux de moi ça le rapt et
émoustiller de trouvait couché dans mon
lit avec couche tard est semblable à
salue les hommes ne sont capables que de
sentiments hajek tch alors quoi il vous
a écrit les vous voir ah non il m'a
envoyé loupiac sont associés vous savez
oui et qu'est ce que vous lui avez
répondu à loupiac qu'il fallait que je
vous consulte
bon eh bien je vous défends de retourner
à votre mari vous fâchez pas
il marche et la prod péremptoire qu'il
redoute le froid sec et qu'il prend
enfin conscience de certains procès car
oui oui points et est une canaille
il n'a jamais cessé de vous tromper vous
avez appris quelque chose
ah oui
ah oui ça j'ai appris quelque chose
faite en haut ça je n'ai pas pris en
flagrant délit mais c'est tout comme
j'ai quand je les ai lu les lettres de
pointe est mon cher ce site je
t'embrasse as eu ton placide et
débonnaire et le style ordinaire des
maris des baux chic et et marie sont
débauchés et tous les hommes le sont à
non ça ne vous raccommoder pas avec
votre mari tient trop apprêtée ce procès
vous fatiguez pas j'y tiens pas moi mon
mari nous n'allons pas qui m'amuse plus
figée mon amant celui qu'on va les
conseillers prendre moi moi je vous ai
conseillé prendre un amant et vous
m'avez bien vu qu'il fallait qu'ils se
marier ah pardon
ne confondons pas je suis avocate tue
pas entremetteuses
je vous ai dit dans l'intérêt de votre
cause que si les exigences de votre
tempérament vous pousser dans les bras
d'un homme il valait mieux qu'il fut
mariée c'est à dire plus prudent et plus
discret carnot c'est tout ce que je
voulais dire bon vous l'avez trouvé cet
homme là ah oui marié discret dans sa il
a été dans les commencements
il a mis à jour à me dire son nom un non
noble avec une particule non tout d'un
coup il se met à s'afficher partout avec
moi dans les bois dans les deux cas on a
un coût de ce train dangereux pour vous
ça mon petit avis c'est bien ce que je
me dis aussi moi je suis prudente pour
deux années hier soir on a été faire la
ribouldingue avec des amis à quoi la
ribouldingue larry gold a décidément
tout paris était en fête hier soir
et la soirée s'est terminée au
commissariat de police et bien malgré
que j'ai bu un peu trop de champagne
j'ai pas perdre une lors quand on m'a
demandé mon nom j'ai donné celui de mon
amant pour si sa femme apprend qu'elle
va en faire une tête en effet dit moi ça
se passe et où votre ribouldingue aura
morts
au ces messieurs ne se sont pas battus
avec des américains ainsi ils n'ont pas
cassé deux glaces vous n'avez pas eu une
crise de nerfs si il ne s'appelle pas le
baron de mérode votre âme en allant vrai
quoi achour qui va un peu loin vais
passer mon avis oui et le heureusement
que c'est tabou qu'il est rapide détail
raconter ça j'ai bien c'est un vieux
clients à vous mais tout de même
un client mais c'est chez vous que je
vais rencontrer le jour je suis venu
vous apporter les lettres de mon mari il
m'a dit qu'il avait avec vous une
affaire qui dure depuis plus de sept ans
[Musique]
il vous a dit ce tapis mepi m'embrasser
sur la bouche et il m'a dit qu'il
m'aimait comme ça tout de suite penser
comme ça tout de suite ça c'est du
propre
comment ils vous choisissez le jour où
ce brave pointe et oubliant vôtre vous
offrent généreusement de lui de vous
pardonnez moi je suis petit cécile je
t'embrasse à un bras a pointé pour
ajouter une une trahison supplémentaires
à toutes celles que vous avez déjà vous
reprochez à face à vous en avez une
façon de me défendre que vous êtes
changeantes
moi je comprends plus bas vous allez
comprendre
mais bon quoi oh oh il va répondre ça du
moment que vous êtes là également très
évidemment et non et qui sait non mon
mari mes affaires ne regarde pas votre
médication un peu ma demande et colette
au cc leur bonjour petite cécile je sais
toi qu'ils appellent juju la bcbe
service et c'est moi oui à cause de ma
jeunesse persistante et de mon caractère
badin ou alors ça comme cynisme voire du
tout pas du tout je ne suis pas cynique
du tout mais comme j'ai horreur de
l'hypocrisie et du mensonge alors pris
n'y ait aucun malentendu entre nous
n'est ce pas ma femme ma maîtresse alors
les parents de l'annoncé tenu des trams
sont très mauvaises d'ailleurs mon nom
et edmond bolbec
je suis désolé si j'avais su que joujou
de mérode c'était votre mari je ne
saurai jamais raconté tout ce que je
vous ai raconté tout à l'heure j'en
doute pas madame qu'est ce que c'est
embêtant encore falloir que tu changes
d'allemand à n'a pas du tout à ma copine
tu vas changer d'avocat mais pendant la
nuit si tu as changé d'avocat à moins
que m bolbec qui fait passer par dessus
tout c'est de voir professionnel né à
coeur de continuer à non non non moi à
ma sérénité de leroy jusque là non je
laisse à mes confères du soin de plaidé
l'insoutenable cause de cette créature
allait pas contente tu sais jusqu'où il
vaudrait mieux rond mais non je te dis
durant toi tu m' attends chez toi et je
viens te prendre pour dîner comme
d'habitude comme d'habitude et comme
comme d'habitude quelques à froid
[Musique]
dis donc en l'état devient forme ou quoi
nommé de quel droit est ce que tu parles
sur ce ton là à ma maîtresse un tel que
l'a expliqué très gentiment cette petite
elle pouvait pas deviner que j'étais ton
mari d'ailleurs si quelqu'un mérite des
reproches dans cette affaire c'est par l
elysée pour moi non plus abbas et moi
peut-être incontestablement oui bah ça
je connais la tactique tu prévenir mon
attaque en attaquant à vieux procédés
seulement tous les trucs des prévenus je
les connais tu perds ton temps tu n'es
pas d'une époque mais écolo si tu
réfléchis c'est 30 secondes met pas en
avocate en femme
eh bien tu t'apercevras que je n'ai pas
besoin d'employer des procédés et comme
tu dis parce que si quelqu'un mérite des
compliments dans toute cette affaire
c'est bien moi un des compliments pour
avoir une maîtresse non pas avoir
attendu sept ans avant d'en prendre une
et encore encore en suppliant de mon
opéra wattu m'a supplié rappelle toi
le jour où je t'ai attendu dans le salon
que tu marchais au client je t'ai dis
j'en ai par dessus la tête je vais faire
quelque chose tu m'a même pas écouter si
je l'écoutais tu m'as dit allez met le
fête au village ou un bar d'hôtel ça
voulait dire je vais prendre une
maîtresse et bien m'aimer mais moi non
plus je ne savais pas que j'allais
prendre une maîtresse moi je n'en savais
rien je t'ai mis en garde
je t'ai dit je vais faire un geste
sensationnel et définitif eh ben j'ai
fait celui là mais by le [ __ ] agraire
oui et je n'ai qu'un regret cette part
il va penser plutôt toi on aurait dû
plutôt séparer nos vies sentiments et
ben il n'est jamais trop tard pour bien
faire nous la leur nous allons laisser
pareille nos existences qui allait
radicalement c'est moi qui t'ai une
parfaite tu veux divorcer
oui l'appartement la raison d'ailleurs
c'est le plus à seulement 10 dans
attention ne compte pas sur moi pour
prendre tous les torts à ma charge
ça ma bienveillance n'ira pas jusque là
alors s'apprendre lecteurs et elle n'ira
aboa parce que tu penses que je laissais
les temps très peur laisse parler mon
avocat il prendra tue 500 me regarde on
se retrouve devant les tribunaux
bolbec contre bolbec et ce procès là je
te mets au défi de le gagner colère et
non un film on n'écoute franchement ça
sans colère et sans mauvaise foi
mais qu'est ce que tu me rapproche
ce que je tenais réfléchi colette
réfléchi qu'est ce qu'il me reste à moi
quand tu reviens de l'audience 1 une
loque un vrai aussi fatigué vie des
vannes et qui ne demande qu'à dormir
alors tu te mets à table
attendu que ses services tu manges
attendu que tu as faim puis fandor
nonobstant appel et si je veux
travailler tu déposes des conclusions
c'est clair ça c'est très spirituel
alors alors voilà donc tout ce que tu as
à me reprocher un ma carrière mais oui
ma femme travaille quand je vais me
sentir habitants sur je ne sais pas non
je ne m'amuse pas attention je prends
une maîtresse c'est tout différent
je vais chercher ailleurs la campagne
que je ne trouve plus ici d'ailleurs je
n'ai fait que suivre les préceptes à
quoi enfin c'est bien toi qui avait
amassé s'il cadets à cécile pour celui
des deux conjoints qui est délaissé par
l'autre a le droit de tromper
oui je sais jamais dit si enfin c'est
l'idée tu lui as dit que celui des deux
qui délaisse l'autre à tous les corps
sans vie ont même j'ai dit ça j'ai dis
ça je dis ça moi qui sais pas moi voilà
on dit anton ceci tentons cela ça dépend
des cas la semaine dernière encore oui
j'ai fait acquitter une femme qui avait
tué son mari parce qu'il a trompé mais
j'ai trouvé des arguments irréfutables
pourtant je ne tue pas pas encore
après il manquerait plus que sa priorité
à part ça ce serait le comble alors
comment tu ne me regardent même pendant
sept ans et quand enfin un jour par
hasard tu t'aperçois que j'existe tu
veux me tuer non même école
sapristi mais quand tu m'a épousée tu le
savais que j'avais passé ma thèse et ma
licence en fait ce n'est pas pris en
traître
la première année notre mariage n'est je
n'ai pas ouvert un livre de droit j'ai
même pas mis les pieds au palais et puis
il ya eu une boule par gsm bull bosses
tu te rappelles bull basse
enfin ce pauvre type qui avait volé deux
mille francs dans un hôtel oui boulbon
ma personne voulait le défunt qui était
inscrite au barreau m'a nommé depuis
squattent un hacker fusée mais j'ai par
cru que ça m'entraîne j'ai improvisé ma
plaidoirie comme ça en quelques heures
j'étais admirable alors le bâtonnier m'a
fait appeler ma vie j'avais un avenir à
ne pas négliger et des trois jours après
j'avais une autre affaire et puis nous
montrer qu'une autre mais qu'est ce que
tu veux saleté l'engrenage voilà
l'engrenage
alors tu n'es pas fier d'avoir une femme
dont on parle
voilà une femme dont on parle et elle
est vraiment bonne qu'à plaider notre
divorce
c'est inouï tu me présente 2013 et c'est
toi qui me fait une scène mais
parfaitement parce que c'est ta faute
tout ce qui arrive moi homme vertueux
par principe et par tempérament je t'en
veux de mai trahison que ça par exemple
je ne te pardonnerai jamais de t'avoir
tromper
et réfléchir que s'ils pensaient mois
apprend d'une maîtresse et puis tu crois
que ça m'amuse d'aller faire la fête
dans des cabarets avec un coût non car
tour dorée sur la tête fait jeter des
petites boules de celluloïd partout est
ce que tu crois que ça m'amuse moins de
me battre avec des américains 1 parce
qu'il me surface et contraint par mois à
prendre une maîtresse été chercher la
femme la plus bête que j'aie jamais
rencontré mais c'est précisément parce
qu'elle est bête que je les choisis je
vis depuis 7 ans avec un être supérieur
qui ne m'écoute jamais quand je lui
parle alors c'est tout naturel j'ai été
séduit par la naïveté de cette petite
elle est simple et directe elle est
stupide elle m'écoute et elle me
comprend l'ema pour toi tu sais très
bien ce que je veux dire
comme elle n'a rien à faire elle est
toujours à ma disposition si nous
sortons ensemble elles me demandent où
veux tu allais et si je raconte devant
telle une histoire comique qu'il connaît
par coeur et brille à chaque fois ah bah
oui et si le temps se rafraîchit elle me
dit joujou mais allen
ah ouais c'est ça et bah oui eh bah oui
eh ben voilà
oui
un à l'air de rien ces petites choses
doit connaître mais c'est très important
et ben moi ça me manquait mais si ma
femme de temps en temps des sandales
tout petit peu de son piédestal et me
disait des choses comme ça et bien je
t'assure que jamais tu m'entends jamais
je n'aurais été m'adresser ailleurs
parce que je t'aime mais colette tu sais
d'ailleurs je t'aime encore je n'ai
jamais aimé que toi enfin rends-toi
conte cécile mais c'est rien pour moi
c'était un quart d'heure 2-2 de
récréation même pas tandis que toi toi
connaître enfin se souvient doivent
notre merveilleux voyage de noces à
athènes 1 oui ah oui c'était beau à des
ouïes hession brume la gloriette et puis
et puis bayreuth
et puis cette merveilleuse
représentation de tristan et iseult
pourquoi est-ce qu'il ya colette non tu
pourrais pas comprendre
or si je t'assure que si on ne parle
plus d'affaires judiciaires c'est très
capable de contrôler non mais ici non
non c c'est très difficile
je t'en supplie colette et bien si tu
étais resté l'homme que tu étais là bas
je ne serai peut-être jamais depuis la
femme que je suis j'ai changé mais ce ne
sont pas les compliments du bâtonnier ni
même mon succès dans la sphère boulba ce
qu'ils ont décidé de ma carrière et mais
même cette affaire bull basse et bien
j'aurais tout de suite refusé d'appeler
des 6 et quand nous sommes rentrés à
paris après selon ce ce merveilleux
voyage de noces que nous sommes
installés dans cet appartement tout neuf
j'étais tout de suite occupé ton petit
confort à toi temps pour fauteuils telit
alors j'étais un peu déçu tu voi à la
place de l'amant passionné je découvrais
d'un seul coup le petit bourgeois
ponctuelles
tandis qu'enfin un marbre mais colette
je te jure que ne je n'ai jamais aimé
que toi je dis pas non seulement j'avais
cessé d'être ta maîtresse
j'étais devenue la maîtresse de maison
au col du bois edmond pour obtenir d'une
femme ce que tu attendes moyens il faut
pas seulement l'attirer à toi il faut
aussi aller un peu vers elle en fallait
étudier la comprendre alors tu auras été
aimé par une femme au lieu d'être égayée
par une petite dame qui se donnent au
premier jeu ne demandait qu'à aimer moi
l'amour tu vois je ne croyais pas être
capable de regretter l'amour à ce point
là enfin pourquoi dis-tu de le regretter
comme si ta vie était finie on n'a qu'à
tout recommencer mais reconnaissent des
cours mais notre vie conjugale depuis le
jour où elle a commencé à te déplaire tu
veux tiens tu n'est plus avocat tu es
simplement une jeune femme qui aime son
mari et que son mari adoré du fou et en
os afin de ne pas jeter au panier cette
année mal vécue comme une lettre mal
écrite je suis maître bolt est bien
décidé de ne plus l'être et une le sang
et or je t'en supplie peux t'en supplie
colette ne plaident plus redevient une
femme je te jure que moi je redeviendrai
l'amant que que tu regrettes est tout à
l'heure non mes clients enfin ma
carrière mais mais qu'est-ce qu'on va
dire au palais air mais qu'est-ce qu'on
va dire et parodies rasteau feu ont dû
rater malin que tu as besoin de partir
en voyage où on dira tout simplement que
tu aimes ton mari tu sais c'est une
raison qui peut très bien ça de maistre
je ne dis pas nous mais quoi faire
réfléchir c'est énorme tas hutois quoi
moi ta maîtresse je pense et plus je te
vois là écoute c simple elles pendant le
dîner je lui ferai parvenir à un mot du
restaurant c'est tout du restaurant nous
dînons pas ici
ah non on sort mais qu'est ce que tu
passes heureuse si si enfin je ne sais
pas si ça me fait peur bah demain tu n'y
pensera plus dire je veux dire à léonie
de sortir ta plus belle robe col est
collé on va être heureux ensemble comme
comment l'a jamais été
colette je t'aime
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui certainement
[Applaudissements]
oui mais sûrement 6 cm si monsieur ben
je ne sais nous fait très plaisir qu'on
vienne demain tôt des directives je vais
regarder sur notre carnet si nous avons
quelque chose pour demain non y'a rien
non je m'engage sans en parler à colette
vous savez si elle avait pris quelque
chose
elle me l'aurait dit certainement à non
mais maintenant elle va plus au palais
du tout un os non là c'est fini ça non
vous voyez un homme heureux
enfin vous l'entendez vous le verrez
demain voilà je vous remercie pour votre
invitation je n'y manquerai pas bien sûr
voir vous voyez quelqu'un vient
d'apporter un petit piqué pour madame
oui et qu'est ce que c'est c'est la
partie de la parfumerie le jour où je me
suis donné quinze mille francs un flacon
quinze mille fois elle même j'ai pensé
c'est pour ça que je tenais demandé à
monsieur vous dit pas si c'est de la
parfumerie il faut il faut il faut payer
et puis vietnam qui attend ça c'est fini
maintenant les clients c'est terminé
achetez pas un pion madame béatrice
lingère qui disparaît littéralement sous
d'immenses carton bourse est bien décrit
sur le tour ma femme qu'elle l'attend
elle entrera la recevra n'est ce pas de
deux alors ça non ça n'est pas possible
monsieur valentin monsieur je vous ai
dit que je ne voulais plus voir un seul
dossier ici je ne les tolère que dans
votre bureau et encore pendant 15 jours
15 jours seulement mais oui je vous ai
donné un mois pour liquider les affaires
courantes il ya de cela quinze jours 5
sur 10 quittent aussi facilement que ça
monsieur bolbec nous avons au moins ici
350 dossiers n'oubliez pas vos alors au
moins la zone message
ça se tire j'ai une longue entrevue la
semaine dernière avec m vauxrot il a
accepté le report mi trentaine
d'affaires
oui je ne vous parle pas du courrier qui
est affolant ce matin il y avait encore
bien entendu vous ne communiquez aucune
de ces lettres mafieux un entendu
d'ailleurs elle m'a dit elle même
qu'elle ne voulait pas jolie brune
cependant il y en a une ce soir qui est
arrivé à laquelle il est bien difficile
que madame bolbec ne répondent pas
personnellement à bord de kindu
bâtonnier ça
je vous permettre de vous lâcher
j'aimerais bien voilà voilà
nommons chez remettre ma chère amie
madame gilbert maurice on sort de chez
moi il paraît que vous renoncez
décidément a plaidé sa cause elle est
absolument désemparé me demande mon avis
sur le choix d'un autre avocat
j'estime que ce procès doit être plaidée
par une femme avant de lui conseiller
maître yvonne carteret
je tiens à faire une dernière démarche
auprès de vous réfléchissez cette
affaire pourrait être le plus grand
succès de votre carrière bien
amicalement avoue le batteur des doors
celle là il faut absolument pas qu'elle
a donné à moi j'y répondrai moi même
personne aveugle que comme vous voudrez
valentin votre départ me cause à la fois
du soulagement et du regret au monsieur
mais aussi du soulagement parce que ça
met fin à une période qui pour moi était
maudite et du regret parce que
personnellement je n'ai jamais eu à me
plaindre de vos services vous avez
trouvé une nouvelle situation et je n'ai
pas cherché monsieur mais alors c'est
une raison je renonce au bar a bondi à
comme ma femme
oui monsieur oui oui et pour les mêmes
raisons comment jugez vous êtes vous est
une femme que votre métier agacé c'est
par amour pour elle que vous renoncez à
votre non non non pas du tout parce que
pas du tout pas du tout moi je veux
faire de la littérature
et puis j'estime que comme moi quand on
a eu l'honneur d'être le collaborateur
immédiat de m bolbec on doit s'en tenir
là servir quelqu'un d'autre à présent se
serait déchoir naturellement évidemment
d'un autre côté je ne peux pas leur en
vouloir d'avoir voulu re devenir une
femme mais non vous savez que c'est à
cause de moi qu'elle a vu c'est signé
c'est amusant quand on y pense mais
depuis quinze jours je suis toujours le
secrétaire de m bolbec seulement voilà
il n'ya plus de mettre vollebekk
[Rires]
soit bonjour mon chéri alors tu t'es
bien amusé deux essayages un vernissage
raté deux cocktails et une remise de
légion d'honneur a juste une pile à
temps
je suis mort mais je suis contente a
très content mais ce n'est pas ça pour
me faire plaisir tu le pense
comment si je le pense valve et parce
que cette transformation opérée si si
rapide si brusque de si soudaine
qu'inespérée aussi à mon nom je suis
très sincère je t'assure non non
brusquement cuma replonge les dents dans
une existence que j'avais oublié pour
laquelle décidément je suis fait non
l'eau l'autre n'aura été qu'un qu'un
détour je retombe dans à prévoir mais
alors tu du même et bien entendu mon
chéri bien entendu je t'aime
bon et bien leur jeu je dois je dois
être heureux
et pourquoi tu ne lis pas le signe si si
si mais j'espère dit pas autant que je
l'espérais et doux
parce que tu vois cette nouvelle route
que je t'ai fait prendre
on ne peut pas dire qu'elles conduisent
beaucoup plus vers moi que l'autre quoi
ça non mais non mais si tu ne travailles
plus ça c'est une affaire entendue ma
femme on ne sera pas beaucoup plus
souvent qu'avant
ah non non ce qu'il faut entendre
reprend des esprits depuis quinze jours
je n'ai pas pris un seul repas sans toi
oui mais presque jamais avec moi tout
seul abadie en ce moment sont des
invitations tous les côtés elle se verra
bien tient un propos et votre jeunesse
qu'à téléphoner nous attend demain à
claques s'est passé ce jour que nous
avions de libre
ah et bien tu vas lui téléphoner que
nous n'y allons pas très content car ça
sort très content mais redit dans si je
comprends bien la journée de demain nous
allons la passer tous les deux ensemble
certainement jusqu'à 4 heures
seulement oui oui ya je ne sais pas
combien de temps que j'ai pas vu cette
pommade dalmat téléphoné hier qu'elle
était un peu souffrante à leurs rêves
j'irai la voir oui alors dans ce cas là
je préfère ne pas des commandes et les
vannes je ne veux tu vois pas pourquoi
au fond tu lui en veut encore à mabhida
oui on écoute ce fini tout ça c'est
oublié non non non je lui en veux parce
qu'elle a été très désagréable avec moi
d'accord ya trois jours dans un
embouteillage nos voitures se sont
arrêtées par hasard l'une à côté de
l'autre elle s'est mise à hurler pour
couvrir le bruit des moteurs en me
demandant des nouvelles de ma vessie
bien entendu les gens se sont retournés
maa pour changer de conversation j'ai
parlé de toi
et là elle a crié littéralement abbas
est vrai qu'elle ne travaille plus
méfiez-vous
et puis c'est passé au vert et sa
voiture est partie heureusement pour moi
d'aller stupide magda que je lui
donnerai je lui dirai demain matin sont
de penser non que ne la lui dira pas
puisque nous allons chez les vannes je
ne décidément tu y tiens oui bah c'est
entendu ils ont beaucoup ce que m'a dit
'ça magda méfiez vous qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça est-ce que tu as encore à
te plaindre de moi non mon chéri je mixe
du tout haut mais qu'est ce que tu sens
bon vin nouveau pas fait qu'on leur a
bon le le jour où je me suis donné mais
je les ai essayé cet après midi j'ai
trouvé formidable alors quoi alors j'ai
dit qu'on recommande livre un plat
conditions ces pêcheurs tu sais que 3000
francs
que 3000 francs oui trois mille fois oui
dites-le à propos de à propos de
livraison tu sais qu'il ya une dame là
qui t'attend tu perds tu me l'a dit j'y
pense et plus je vais la voir elle
m'apporte des merveilles dont il sera
vous quelle heure est il c'est un bassin
en bas il faut que je me dépêche je vais
m'habiller madame c'est chic - tu fais
comment même pointer je crois au frais
elle m'apporte peut-être les honoraires
conduisait là monsieur bah non c'est à
me demander à madame ou monsieur dit que
c'est urgent bon bah ils se vendent à
toi ou moi le frappe mais qu'est ce que
ça veut dire sois gentil reçoit là il
est si tard comment mes collègues mes
enfants réfléchissent
ça ne te gêne pas que ce soit moi qui le
reçoit je voudrais tout de même pas que
ce soit jalouse
oui c'est vrai je te demande pardon oui
ça doit être moi je suis toujours trop
exigeant décidément 10 dont colette we
may propos on l'a livré ton nouveau
parfum 1
je les payais et ben tu as bien fait oui
15000 francs
ben oui c'est ça je sais ce que je t'ai
dit tout à l'heure
valora tout sinon j'ai vu je me dépêche
cette entrée madame pointait
si vous qui vous recevez monsieur van
beck et oui si vous n'y voyez pas
d'inconvénient madame pointé je
m'attendais à ce que ce soit la dernière
fois que je suis venu ici madame bolbec
m'a traitée de créatures je comprends
qu'ils soient désagréables de me revoir
et qu'est ce qui me vaut le plaisir de
votre visite mon divorce toujours en
avion va bientôt pdg besoin de mon
dossier est alors vous venez le
cherchons vous l'a pas renvoyer et gants
au mais c'est en croit asseyez-vous
valentin ballon cafouillé gentil
rechercher le dossier de temps vous
l'aurez pouvez vous ramenez et dites moi
vous êtes contente de votre nouvel
avocat très content oui et puis avec lui
au moins je suis sûr d'avoir ma portion
de 500 mille francs par mois ça alors je
veux qu'on ne sait jamais moi je sais
pas bon parce que si mon mari n'est pas
condamné par le tribunal à plat données
c'est lui qui me la donnera
non mais je qui lui pour la voter bon
mais c'est interdit et comment
s'appelle-t-il pourquoi parce qu'il est
marié et que c'est mon amant oui c'est
même pour ça qu'il s'est engagé à verser
les 500 milles faut il a commencé
d'ailleurs un bon et il ne s'arrêtera
que si mon mari est condamné d'avancé
civam le pds moi c'est là et vous êtes
gérer avec les enfin je dis vous pensez
que ça va durer un petit peu plus
longtemps que d'habitude si pas encore
leur ai annoncé dans ce nom
c'est difficile vous sourit de trouver
l'âme ans qu'il vous faut oh là là et
votre mari ne vous a pas proposé de vous
reprendre asi même que j'ai pas voulu
oh bah vous avez du temps avec les idées
bourgeoise que vous avez il fallait
accepter
elles n'ont pas vraiment ça ça me dirait
rien avant de vous aider les
raccommodages ça tient jamais non on
fait une reprise puis ça craque un autre
endroit fait dit ça parce que vous
n'avez jamais vraiment aimé votre mari
pardon monsieur malbec
c'est le seul homme que j'aime et alors
dont six au début il était gentil
empressé je les adorais et puis est
cassé et cassé voyez-vous monsieur
vollebekk l'amour ça peut sera commencée
bien sûr mais pas avec le même à aa
vous avez l'air tout drôle tout d'un
coup qui n'ont pas du tout c'est ce que
je vous ai dit sous les raccommodages
mais ça ça prive pas du tout avoue 9ème
temps je me dis ça parce que je ne veux
pas que vous pensiez que je vous ai dit
mes chances qui dit que j'étais une
garde le nom je tenais voilà votre
dossier connaît le jeu vous reconduire
un pointeur merci jules
monsieur valentin vous verrez ma femme
voulait dire est que je m'habille
excusez-moi de vous avoir prévenus si
longtemps monsieur wolberg pendule pour
tout le plaisir a été pour moi madame
point m au revoir je joue bien valentin
qu'est ce que vous faites là tout seul
si vous attendez votre mari m'a chargé
d'une commission pour laquelle ils
s'habillent nous avons dix minutes
il vous a chargé de me dire que nous
avions 10 min au nom ne vous moquez pas
de mal les dix minutes je voulais
demander valente a vous de me les
demeures des riez pas si vous saviez ce
que j'ai dit dieu quoi quoi quoi quoi
voilà à deux mains je ne peux pas au
pourquoi mais pourquoi pourquoi mon mari
a accepté une invitation sans m'en
parler en mal j'ai fait tout pour
l'éviter g j'ai inventé une visite un
magnat crown scène mais ça n'a pas pris
alors alors qu'est ce que vous voulez
j'ai pas voulu insister davantage aurait
fini par éveiller ses soupçons
enfin c'est comme ça demain il ne faut
pas compter sur oh ça sera pour un autre
jour mais comme vous me dites son entrée
on dirait que ça vous fait plaisir ça ne
va pas de main oui non non non non en
fait moi je ne sais pas
là vraiment râlant teint foncé tellement
invraisemblable tout ce qui m'arrive
alors je m'attendais steepler gt s'ils
ont les mois et moi qui vous apparaît en
silence depuis si longtemps
et puis un beau jour vous maintenant ce
que vous renoncez à votre carrière que
je dois liquider vos dossiers c'est mon
départ mon moment congé alors je vous ai
regardé n'ai pas compris vous m'avez
regarder aussi on s'est regardé cette
révélation 7 7 minutes
et puis les quinze jours qui ont suivi
puis et puis colette nous nos
rendez-vous et enfin que l'école est le
baiser
depuis trois ans et ce premier baiser là
qu'ils étaient vivants que les collègues
colette ne quittez pas laisser avec moi
vivons toujours ensemble au salon saint
éloi aussi s'y coller je vous aime
colette reconnaître comme la valeur mais
pas ici
mais quand on coco quoi donner samedi
samedi à gaza le vieux samedi reçoit
d'abord m baromètre métro coupable dans
les dossiers d'appel oui m m d'euros et
que je vais construire
il a critiqué ce matin devant l article
412 précision d'esprit vis une rapidité
dont vous êtes a encore tout ému ce qui
me tue allons sévir
avant nous étions en train de parler
d'une affaire passionnante qui soulève
un point de droit est extrêmement
émouvant et hué bi gohorey fonctionne
dépêche vous m'avez comprise valentin
non si vous n'avez plus besoin de moi on
dit vous non plus monsieur n'est vrai
non plus bon bon boulot alors je vais
prendre en note que vous m'avez dit et
puis épuisement nivet voilà voilà voilà
au revoir madame bonjour monsieur
au revoir valence va le valentin
[Applaudissements]
alors tu m'as tiens ici à mon chéri je
je vais m'habiller
c'est ça haut en ce qu'il te va bien
quand nouveau smoking oui c'est le même
depuis quatre ans un suisse unia oui oui
ghazir non non je voulais dire qu'elle
est aujourd'hui
enfin je me dépêche
c'est pas possible comme j'aurais pas
fait tout ça pour quelqu'un d'autre non
surtout beau il faut que je fasse
quelque chose moi je ne sais pas encore
quoi mais il faut que je fasse quelque
chose qui est assurée biskoul demande à
voir m vol d'accueil et mixé tour
j'avais ma femme est sortie moi aussi on
est tous sortir des trolls terre qu'est
ce que je pourrais bien que moi des
sorties comme il n'est pas sorti mais
laissez-nous monsieur en question de
parler à monsieur bolbec à le mari m'a
tant le marié oui monsieur je vous
assure de m'accorder de ville une bombe
a laissé noir c'est noir tueur
monsieur j'ai absolument besoin de
parler à m bolt est oui est ce que vous
êtes un de ses clients oui monsieur oui
je suis au regret elle n'exerce plus
mesure ce plu non c'est vrai il y avait
un bureau avant mais oui là ce n'est
plus avocat non comme je suis une
catastrophe oui ça le mot n'est pas trop
fort
mais son secrétaire est encore là si
vous voulez je peux aller l'enjeu
secrétaire moi non plus ne sait
absolument besoin de parler à m bolbec
ben écoutez monsieur dans d'autres
circonstances j'aurais demandé à ma
femme n'aurait pas la tête à ça
ni moi non plus d'ailleurs parce que la
vie est bien dit c'est ça monsieur par
mail et parlé parlé ici c'est la fille
tuée
le cas racontent leurs petites affaires
personnelles mais par me parlait plus
ensuite moi je vous parlerai tout ce qui
m'arrive croyez moi c'est pas ordinaire
ah non mais je la connais moi votre
histoire
ah ah oui ma femme me l'a raconté un
jour pour m'amuser à quoi vous abusez
pas si le début vous a paru plaisant
monsieur la suite vous allez mourir de
rire
aïe aïe aïe parce qu'il ya une suivi
monsieur galice huit mois joseph roduit
school au fisc et académie le plus
honnête homme dans toute l'acceptation
du terme récepteur jr je suis accusé de
vol avec effraction et tentative
d'assassinât
eh ben c'est bien ça commençait bien
chambre qu'est ce que vous voulez
griffard commence que jamais je veux que
vous usiez de vos prérogatives des poux
dès que vous exigiez que m avec serait
en tout cas moi de mettre un bol l'ex
occupant venait de me raconter ce qui
vous est arrivé depuis votre dernière
visite à damas sur les conseils de m
bolbec
je suis allé au coffre-fort oui je
voulais y prendre deux cent cinquante
mille francs juste deux cent cinquante
mille francs
je suis le plus jeune et hop dans toute
l'acceptation exception et me présenter
avec nu devant ma fiancée comme le
désirait métro balma et puis arrivé
devant le coffre-fort malédiction
j'avais perdu la clé ah ah
alors que faire il restait plus qu elle
forcément moi je ne sais pas forcer les
propres efforts alors je me suis souvenu
des relations que j'avais avec monsieur
bibi la tignasse un client de maître
bolbec
alors j'ai plus joindre à l'hôtel de
l'univers et de l'aquitaine réunis oui
ça y est
oui bah alors quand il m'a vu il m'a dit
redit school food et j'irai encore une
lettre de recommandation
il parle comme ça arrive à vous le
connaissez pas du tout ah ben vous
présenterez on va quand il sortira de
prison
bon alors je lui dis non monsieur la
tignasse je voudrais forcer un coffre
fort seulement je ne sais pas voulez
vous me donner un coup de main cette
mesure au disco alors nous prenons
rendez vous chez monsieur bouillotte à
11 heures il a été très exact nous
mentons il regarde de le coffre-fort et
il me dit que tu travailles bon et en
effet ça a été d'une simplicité il a
sorti de sa poche un objet d'apparence
inoffensive
et puis brusquement cédé du feu ça date
un chalumeau voilà voilà un seul un
chalumeau je t'aime bien est géré en cd
c'est pratique ça vous perçu une plaque
de forums une motte de beurre s'est fait
un nom moi je regardais ça avec
admiration montant tout à coup la porte
s'ouvre et le concierge compte il avait
entendu du bruit alors livre des mois ce
qui se passait alors bibi la tignasse
pose son chalumeau et se retournant vers
moi me dit textuellement mon pote
en effet faut que je descende moi j'ai
pas très bien compris ce sont des
locutions qui mettait pas familière
alors je lui réponds fait don ca et le
voilà qui tue le concierge à coups de
marteau c'est son arme favorite alors le
preuve le concierge proteste poussent
des cris assourdissants
les voisins mais on a arrêté bibi latina
ce n'est pas vous mais non moins ce que
laisse un petit escalier l'heureux je me
suis déjà rivés sur entré chez moi très
contrarié parce que je n'ai pas mes deux
cent cinquante mille fois avec j'ai pas
de veine le concierge non plus nantes
nous nourrir
alors ce matin en ouvrant les journaux
qu est ce que j non mais qu'est ce que
j'y lis le crime du faubourg saint denis
un concierge est assassiné par deux
voyous on arrête bibi la tignasse qu'on
recherche remise cool que c'est une
infamie moins value mois d'assassins
mais je suis un honnête homme peut se
servir du terme
ça n'est pas moi qui ai martelé le
concierge lui en donne ma parole
d'honneur
il faut que m bolbec me saoule écrit mon
innocence
bon écoute et je crois que cette cause
est intéressante a plaidé un espace oui
enfin je crois j'espère un vrai pas mais
elle me paraît intéressant à retenir
quand madame sera prêt vous voulez vous
lui demandez quelle est la gentille de
descendre jusqu ici j'ai la vie parler
vous le dirais que c'est urgent
résurgent très urgent car vous savez je
mène une vie infernale même jeu je
m'étais lunettes noires vous avez
remarqué
et puis je longe les murs comme un
criminel j'étais pouvant seulement que
je ne comprends pas très bien étant
donné que vous avez pu vous sauver la
vie pourquoi est-ce qu'on veut vous
arrêtez pourquoi est-ce qu'on vous
accuse
mais c'est bibi la tignasse qui
m'accusent il dit que c'est moi qui suis
venu le chercher et il n'est qu'un objet
entre mes mains criminelles et alors son
avocat va soutenir cette thèse
et qui sait son avocat a nommé florio
florio prix bas ils s'embêtent pas bibi
la tignasse un kia et bien monsieur
robbie school veux te parler
si robbie school oui on écoute pour quoi
que tu pas fait appeler valentin vu ça
ne regarde plus à aimer la gg j'ai cru
quand même qu'il était beau de temps
parler parce que tu sais c'est un
véritable cas de conscience un la sphère
de monsieur revit school prend des
proportions avait servi j'ai lu les
journaux en aval un bonheur on va se
promener à ce que vous avez fait là
monsieur latif a laissé pantois qui
martelait le concierge madame j'ai vu la
tigne ajout de ne pas parle d'un homme
enfin monsieur robbie school on
n'appelle pas ça on aide un assassin
poids de profession mais c'est lui qui
m'avait envoyé alors voilà vous avez su
sentiments sa vie eh bien je vais vous
adresser à mettre vos roues et je vous
en tirerez avec cinq ans 50 points à
cinq ans de prison chacun pour soi mais
joue pour le faire une idée quand je dis
ça je dis ça et crie très fort où il
fait peur aux jurés
vous aurez peut-être que sur 100 mais la
météo qui prévoit il me connaît pas il
m'aime pas je vous adjure de me prendre
ma défense m bolbec
enfin vous les avez pas pris les deux
cent cinquante mille francs mais j'ai
pas eu le temps bon vous l'avez pas
penser au concierge on donne ma parole
d'honneur sur la tête de mon isabelle
bon alors vous êtes une femme n'a pas
besoin de moi mais pivi la tignasse macu
voyous way colette et c'est florian qui
va le défendre ce voyou loriot oui la
tignasse a choisi son avocat vie et
c'est florian vie bon et fleurie rhône
et pour les dames
oui
un joli votre ami l'a dit glace je le
fais a quitté il ya deux ans ils
auraient pu s'adresser à moi tu sais il
a peut-être appris que tu n'exerçait
plus sont très au courant ces gens là la
grève vous n'allez pas défendre latine
ne sont pas moins 20 personnes
je ne défends tout personne posons floro
flores enfin pourquoi diable a dit
accepter cette affaire là enfin qu'est
ce qu'il a dit ça il se tiendra les
affirmations de son client et pour le
sauver l'accusera reviscol en récit pas
d'appuyer quelle preuve la parole de la
tignasse viande on oublie le témoignage
des voisins on a surpris monsieur rugby
school en compagnie de bedie la tignasse
qu'est ce qu'il faisait là voilà un
argument pour florian question était
question que répond quoi missionnaire
pour vous coralie school fidèles
employés s'étaient attardés dans son
bureau il était penché sur sa table de
travail quand il a entendu crier le
concierge
alors lille a bondi il est arrivé pas dû
parfois par quelques secondes avant les
voisins mal et pourquoi s'est-il sauver
les a pas sauvés
il a constaté qu'on arrêtait la tignasse
alors il s'est dit je veux plus rien à
faire ici et et il est rentré
tranquillement chez lui attendre la
suite des événements
et puis enfin messieurs par quel étrange
aberration sept ans maintenant
officier d'un cadet
aurait-il appeler à son secours un voyou
pour forcer le coffre-fort de monsieur
puyol et pourquoi en ré qu'il forçait
son propre record puisqu'il est prouvé
que ledit fouillole puis les 16 500
mille francs car tout est là messieurs
le testament le petit 0 qui est la main
de bouillottes jeu là bas et je le
prouverai robbie schools sa du moment
que j'ai florio en face de moi je
trouverai les experts en écriture qu'il
nous faut il vous sera acquitté jabouri
bon bravo m didon il ment oui si je peux
l'aider encore ce procès-là écoule
colette ne me pose pas de questions on
fait ce que tu crois devoir faire bon et
ben alors je plaide c'est mon jour
robbie school vous pouvez conditions je
sais très bien que mon affaire vous
passionnera vie certaines scènes
et puis florio cei à un moment j'ai
envie de plaider contre lui bon alors
maintenant de perdre droite en europe
vous allez immédiatement vous constituer
prisonnier c'est nécessaire sa dispense
à tous les journaux disent que vous êtes
un assassin et vous ne pourriez pas pour
vous justifier
allez mon avis au commissariat le plus
proche est tout de suite demain matin à
10h j'irai pouvoir au dépôt bombe devant
le commissariat et ensuite le dépenser
je crois comme une affaire prend une
bonne tournée
[Musique]
et tu m'en fais pas trop n'ont pas su
inquiet de te voir te plonger dans ma
phase j'avoue que là c'était quand même
impossible de refuser un espace et puis
enfin il s'agit d'un procès un seul bon
ça qui va bouleverser notre nouvelle
existence
on sort tout de même ce soit mais on
sorte dans le temps on va quand tu m'as
tu es appelé tout à l'heure je me suis
demandé ce qui se passait je me suis
bousculer joie de coiffer comme une
folle moi je sais que ça sérieux c'est
une lettre c'est une lettre que valentin
m'adonnais est pas qu il faut qu'il
réponde de toi même je dois je te croise
est important hier gilbert maurice où
cette affaire pourrait bien être le plus
grand succès de votre carrière et il a
raison
décidément c'est le jour où fait tant
pis qu'est ce que c'est cette lettre
c'est le bâtonnier qui insiste pour que
je plaide encore une affaire bah tu as
raison c'est le jour et c'est vraiment
important très très c'est une jeune
femme de lettres qui avait soumis un
jour sans son manuscrit à un grand
romancier
alors oui enfin c'est une affaire de
plagiat je porte c'est tellement
intéressant tiens j'y pensais encore
avant-hier à cet internaute
c'est peut-être la seule que je regrette
voilà tu vois te voit la reprise par
qu'on maîtrise mais si je te dis que
c'est la seule affaire que je voudrais
vous est maintenant et puis il ya dix
minutes s'étaient remises cool et puis
demain ce sera autre chose
colette je crains que tu ne reste pas
longtemps la petite bourgeoise que tu
avais voulu redevenir tu crois ao non
moi je crois qu'une passion comme la
tienne
on ne peut pas l'étouffer oui nous est
ce que tu te rends compte de ce que tu
dis en fait tu as l'air d'accepter
canada attention je n'accepte pas je
m'incline je me résigne
oui redevenir maître bolbec ne sait
peut-être bien rares
[Musique]
c'est peut-être mieux oui c'est sûrement
mieux on n'est pas pour toi mon écoute
veux tu que je remplace valentin je veux
tu que je devienne ton secrétaire parce
qu'il me semble que depuis quelques
temps il n'est plus tout à fait à sa
place près de toi c'est non mais c'est
une impression
romain tu ne trouves pas c'est possible
un temps dans l'impression et juste
je crois oui il vaut mieux que je me
sépare de lui et bien je le lui dirai de
maintenon pas toi moi et pas demain tout
de suite qu'il veut bien que je le lui
dise tout de suite si tu es chez
valentin s'il vous plaît vous l'aviez le
second
qu'est ce qu'il ya j'allais partir il y
a beaucoup de choses et beaucoup de
choses qui se sont passées depuis
quelques minutes
ah oui d'abord il faut arrêter les
dossiers 1
parce que ma femme a réfléchi et comme
les tellement sollicité de de toutes
parts alors elle a décidé de reprendre
elle-même la direction de ses affaires
or voilà une grande nouvelle vie c'est
pas la seule je me suis brusquement
découvert un goût curieux pour ses
occupations et montlieu comme j'ai fait
un peu de droit je pense que ma place
est auprès d'elle alors ça oblige à se
priver de vos services bien entendu vous
faire vous ne pouvez pas m'en vouloir
insister en étranger encore je
comprendrais mais là le mari n'est fait
si ce fait pas la faire on vous
rappellera
ah oui oui je comprends je comprends
voilà il faudrait peut-être yeux et vous
est prévu que vous preniez congé de ma
femme maintenant rouillés
je vous en prie
au revoir madame adieu maintenant
au revoir monsieur adieu valentin
tu me pardonnes tu as été pas vous en
avait surpris tout à l'heure quand tu
m'avais mis en face de robbie school et
10 mois la lettre du bâtonnier c'est toi
qui l'avais mis exprès là pour que je
l'attends elle suit y est pris à temps
bon alors somme gelée échappé belle
tu l'a échappé belle non mais tu ne m'as
pas encore trompé à non
bon c'était pour ça dit lève la main
droite et dit je le jure glg messier le
président
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la pièce nous avons eu le plaisir
d'interpréter pour vous était de
messieurs georges berre et louise
verneuil
au monsieur roger à
les costumes de donald cardwell
avec marco ville
à la maison
[Musique]
lot de blessés
arlette josselin
michelle rhee
[Applaudissements]
ah le calme
robert manuel
il a réglé la mise en scène
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]